other revenues today in terms of making
any projections on the need to bring
anybody else back at a future date or
whatever else the committee might need
and question for you so that the
presentation today the numbers that
she's giving us you're going to have
populated in that spreadsheet no no not
today no I will it will be at a future
date so excellent everything's moving
quickly for the Department as well as
our office so I didn't have an
opportunity to get it into the worksheet
for today but we don't yeah the whole
point is we don't have to take notes and
enter it into a spreadsheet ourselves
nope you you you can only I mean I'll
give you the worksheet if you want it um
if you want to take notes but you're
going to get a new one that's going to
have the dra ranges on it you're going
to have the worksheet from dra today
that you may want to you know make some
notes
um but yeah I think you should be fine
listening today when she's speaking and
then you know addressing the questions
to who or that you have as it relates to
the various revenues excellent but I
think we're trying to make it very
straightforward for you yeah thank you
good morning
good morning Madam chair members of the
committee Lindsey stepp commissioner New
Hampshire Department of Revenue
Administration hopefully you're not
tired of seeing me yet
no we really have been looking forward
to this actually because you're the nuts
and bolts of what we do so
all right so what you should have in
front of you as Chris mentioned is a
10-page document that
I will go through with you this morning
um
when we are assisting the Committees
with and the LBA with producing the
revenue estimates as I've mentioned
previously we determine the base which
in this case will be fiscal year 2023
and then we look at growth rates
year-over-year growth rates for 24 and
25. so we'll talk numbers for 23 and
then we'll talk growth rates for 24 and
25. I've tried to keep it as simple as
possible
um
to be determined if I was successful but
we will you know we'll spend as much
time as you all need and get you as much
information as you're required to get
through this process
so starting on page one
um we have developed fiscal year 23
through 25 Revenue estimate ranges for
the major taxes that dra administers so
that's the business taxes the meals and
rentals tax tobacco tax interest and
dividends tax communication Services tax
real estate transfer tax and utility
property tax
the estimates were calculated by
adjusting fiscal year 23 Revenue based
on currently available data through
January expected monthly revenues and
considering the impacts of tax law
changes
lastly as you can guess these estimates
are subject to change we will update
them
each month when the final revenue for
the month is determined
and I'd also say these estimates are
probably wrong there are estimates but
we do our best to make them as accurate
as possible
so when we're determining fiscal year 23
the range that we use for the base we do
that based on five different scenarios
that you'll see on page one so the first
scenario is plan if Revenue was just
equal to plan
the second scenario takes actual
year-to-date Revenue through January the
first seven months and assumes plan
revenue for the last five months of 23
based on the general and education trust
fund plan that the department of
administrative Services produces
the third scenario takes actual revenue
for the first seven months and we look
at what our percent difference from plan
has been year to date and we assume that
that percentage difference will maintain
for the last five months so we're
currently 20 ahead of plan we assume
that we'll remain 20 ahead of plan for
the the remaining five months
the fourth scenario takes actual revenue
for the first seven months of 23 and
looks at the percentage difference
compared to Prior year so for 15 ahead
of Prior year we assume we will remain
15 ahead of Prior year for the remaining
five months
and then the last scenario takes Revenue
to date for the first seven months and
looks at what revenue for the last five
months was in the immediate prior year
so in this case in fiscal 22 and we just
add that to the revenue that we've
received to date
we take these five scenarios and that's
what we use to determine the ranges for
23. we run all of the scenarios but
we're only going to present to you those
that we feel are actually likely so for
instance with business taxes we are
significantly ahead of plan so the first
scenario of just Revenue equaling plan
is very unlikely so we're not even going
to give that to you as an option we ran
the scenario we know what it looks like
but it's just not realistic so we
basically take those five scenarios and
say okay based on what we know what do
we feel like are likely high and low
ranges for what we'll see for 23. what
we'll do in this presentation is we'll
just go tax by tax we will
talk about the factors that we're
looking at or that we considered as part
of determining the ranges for 23 and
then the factors that we use to
determine the ranges for 24 and 25.
any questions on these scenarios that we
use to develop 23.
representative alming
thank you
I'm wondering whether in a year like
we've got now if it would
actually make a difference or be useful
if we also looked at the actual revenue
of seven months
of and
and the percentage
above
prior Year from the last three months
only
because things seem to be slowing down
so if we did
the first seven months year to date and
we applied the percent versus prior year
for the for the last three months what
would you want for an estimate for the
two months that are missing because we
need to estimate five more months of
Revenue
yeah that's
the percentage of those five months
oh cool a single percentage for those
five months based on the three months
just to see if we're if we are slowing
It Off
I'm not sure I understand
how we would do that so
right now what we've done in the
year-over-year growth scenario is we've
taken the seven months
we've said that there are for instance
20 percent ahead of Prior year and we've
applied that 20 percent growth to the
prior year actuals
if you only wanted to apply that growth
to the last three months of the prior
year
that would still leave a gap of two
months because we need to estimate five
months of Revenue
we can't take the prior year of the five
months times the increase
in the previous three months
I understand what you're saying now so
you're saying rather than taking year to
date
growth over prior year just take the
last three months of growth
compared to Prior year we can run that
scenario
just
see what it looks like yeah more current
trends representative yes thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my
question Mr steppe
um do you have any scenarios showing
business taxes correlated with grocery
State product
see when we get to the business attack
Slide part of the
um one of the things we looked at in
terms of determining growth rates for
fiscal 24 and 25 was GDP anticipated GDP
growth in the past we have looked at a
correlation between business taxes and
state GDP
um total U.S GDP and we didn't find a
very strong correlation I think it can
inform your decision but it's not an
exact correlation so we have not done
that because based on historical data
the strength of the correlation just
wasn't there if that makes sense but
instead we kind of use it to inform the
growth rates
representative again thank you madam
chair
um back to representative almi's uh
point about the last three months I
guess my concern slash question would be
typically aren't the last three months
of a year pretty strong because
Christmas season is coming up spending
is higher and so we might actually that
actually might be higher than if you go
back five months
that's a good point and we
um did do somewhat of a version of of
that of the scenario that representative
Ami is describing with the real estate
transfer tax because and we'll talk
about that when we get there but
um the the growth in the real estate
transfer tax has been very different
over the last two months January and
February has been much slower than the
prior months of the fiscal year and so
we did account for it in that scenario
um so to answer your question
representative Negan I think we would
want to consider it on a tax by tax
basis to see what makes sense so we can
certainly run the scenarios and then we
can say it makes sense for this tax but
not for that tax that sort of thing yeah
okay
okay on slide two page two
there is a list of adjustments that need
to be applied to fiscal 23 through 25
Revenue to account for various tax law
changes that are not fully accounted for
in the revenues that we've received so
these are changes that are existing in
current law
pending legislation as we talked about
on Monday will be included as Surplus
statement items that the LBA will take
care of so we don't need to right now
think about any of the bills that are
currently before this committee or other
committees in terms of their revenue
impact Chris will work his magic on the
back end with those but what we do need
to account for is changes that are
existing in current law for which we
believe there will be an impact to
revenue and we haven't seen that impact
yet
so for business taxes there are four
items here
um there were rate changes in hb2 from
and there is a rate change in 2022 HB
1221 so that's the first and third line
on the business tax under business taxes
so we will account for those in fiscal
for hb2 credit carryover cap you'll see
an amount in each of the three years
that is the result of that 500 percent
cap that businesses will that will be
enforced on businesses in terms of their
credit carryover for fiscal 23 that will
likely come in the form of refunds
starting in March and April so you see
that 11 million dollars for fiscal 23 it
increases in 24 to 13.5 and then tails
off in 25 to 3.8 million
and then the last change under business
taxes um was the result of a bill passed
last session Senate Bill 435 which
changes how net operating losses are
calculated for businesses and so that
has an 8.6 million dollar impact in 23
and then a 2.1 impact in 24.
in total we're looking at a reduction of
19.6 million for business taxes in 23 25
million in 24 and 3.8 million in 25 so
what we'll do is we'll estimate the
revenues and then we'll just take these
off the bottom
the other change that we need to account
for is with the interest and dividends
tax this is the phase out the reduction
in the IND tax rate that will be 6.3
million this year 22.2 million next year
and 23.4 million in 25. you'll see all
of these these adjustments accounted for
in each of the taxes but I wanted to
provide them here as well so we could
talk about any questions that you had
oh sorry representative thank you on I
sometimes have trouble when I look at
these things
this is
the amount the taxes would go down
each year and so their cumulative you
have to add them together to get to the
effect in 25. correct so these are
what's listed here is year over year
changes because that's how we're
estimating the revenue so we will
determine the revenue apply the
adjustment we will grow the revenue and
apply the year-over-year change that's
correct
okay okay so at the bottom of page two
considering the various scenarios and
adjusting for the tax law changes that
are at the top of the page the dra
determine the following ranges for
fiscal 23 revenues again we'll walk
through these tax by tax on the
remaining slides in the First Column
you'll see the fiscal 23 plan
in the second and third columns you will
see our high and low ranges
and then in the last columns you'll see
how those ranges compare to plan so for
instance for business taxes we have a
range of 1 billion 219 million 500 000
to 1 billion two hundred and fifty Seven
million one hundred thousand and the low
is
261.7 million ahead of plan or 27
percent and the high is
299.3 million or 31 ahead of plan
so this is just kind of a snapshot of
what our estimates look like in terms of
fiscal year 23 compared to plan
representative only has a question thank
you on
this
oh dear I
have a chat heading out of my head
um
yeah we can come back
representative ulery yeah just
just very briefly
um
there's a lot of new folks on here
when you're talking about playing you're
talking about an estimate you're not
talking about real money number one
number two
when like to did today's Revenue came
out 58 Bill a million below plan that
doesn't mean anything
correct
that's a great point so
um plan is that it is an estimate and
notably this estimate was done two years
ago so this was done in January through
June of 21. uh there was a lot of
uncertainty uh during that time and so
these plan numbers
um really were
the best information that the dra and
the legislature had at the time and they
were anticipating a potential Fallout of
revenues and they are very consistent
with what plan was for a number of other
states revenues have performed better in
a lot of cases and so that's why you'll
see this pretty significant especially
with business taxes deviation from plan
in Prior years when we did not have
Global pandemics Etc and revenues were a
little bit more normal you would see
plan and actuals closer together
in terms of
revenues that you see in our daily
revenue reports we are only just barely
at the midpoint of the month this is
when we start reporting revenues to you
so you can see where we are
um at this point in the month however to
representative uluri's point
it really isn't it's nothing to panic
about just yet you'll see revenues
continue to come in especially over the
next few days it's really not until we
get to the last few days of the month
that things kind of Trail off so it's
really just meant to be informative not
meant to spark any significant concerns
at this point in the month and if there
was a reason for a significant concern I
would let you know
foreign
thank you I thought of my question on
take take the business taxes for
instance on the credit carry over cap as
you're calling calling in on why would a
business not on in
March April on
just
reduce the amount of money that they had
to send you
instead of taking a refund
um they may so there's really two ways
that this CCO cap could be felt in terms
of the impact on revenues if businesses
adjusted their estimates knowing that a
certain portion of the amount of credit
that they had on on account was in
excess of what they were going to be
able to keep they could essentially
reduce their estimated payments and Via
reduced estimates use up a portion of
their credit carry forward
that's essentially foregone Revenue it's
Revenue that we just wouldn't receive in
the course of processing the estimates
if a business does not do that when they
get to filing their return in March and
April
the return will essentially calculate
for them that they have exceeded their
CCO cap and will force them to take a
refund for the excess amount
those we will obviously pay out in
refunds the reason why we're showing 11
million dollar impact in 23 is because
what we're seeing is that not all
businesses have reflected the CCO cap in
their estimated payments so we are
anticipating that this CCO cap will
result in a refund the reason why I
think a number of businesses have not
accounted for this cap in their
estimates is one the majority of our
businesses with large credit carryovers
are large multinational businesses
um I believe New Hampshire is the only
state that has this sort of cap on a
credit carryover and so it's probably
something that's just not on the
businesses radar that's not something
that they are actively planning for so
instead it will just result as a refund
on their return
does that answer your question
representative
um most of it okay
yeah but there won't be any way for us
to really tell that that's why they
reduce their estimates next time or
whatever correct correct I mean we can
um look at the the individual taxpayers
with the large credit carryovers and try
to see if they've accounted for it in
their estimates but again
um a reduction in their estimate just
may be a reduction because that's the
trend of their business and not a direct
reflection of the potential cap on the
CCO
the other thing I will mention though
is that as we move through the remaining
five months of fiscal 23
these numbers in that column for
adjustments may change so if we get to
March and April and we feel like we have
seen the impact of the CCO we won't have
that 11 million dollars there anymore so
we are actively watching these
adjustments to make sure that they are
in fact not accounted for in Revenue
received to date if we get to a point
where we believe the revenue received to
date does reflect this tax law change
this adjustment would would be removed
so we're kind of reevaluating it on an
ongoing basis representative Southworth
uh thank you for taking my question but
either way you're going to see the
credit carryovers go down correct which
was our goal correct so no matter which
way they do it you can track that
they're going down the way they're
supposed to correct okay thank you
and so you think you would see that
Trend in March April
we would see in March and April the if
returns are filed granted they could
also be filed on extension and not come
into the fall but if they're filed
timely in March and April we would there
is a line on the return where that CCO
cap is applied so we would see it
to Representatives HealthWorks point we
will
see that the cap has impacted certain
businesses with large ccos
it is likely to reduce the overall CCO
pool but there's also the potential that
there are other businesses that didn't
have a CCO that start generating a CCO
that may cause the total to stay at
higher amounts I don't think it's until
we get to the 250 and the 100 cap that
will really start to see a significant
decline if that makes sense
okay
so we're going to dive right into
business taxes
on page three we're going to rip off the
Band-Aid and we're gonna go head first
okay so I will note that at this point
in the revenue estimating process we
estimate business taxes as a whole we
don't need to worry about splitting out
business taxes between bet and BPT Chris
and I will work on that as we get
further along in the process so right
now we're just going to talk business
taxes as a whole
factors to consider fiscal year to date
we are 146.5 million or 33 percent I had
a plan and we are 26.1 million or 4.7
percent ahead of Prior year
we talked about the tax law changes and
I'll show you in in the chart below
where we take those into account we
talked about during the various
presentations the impact on inflation
um how that raises prices may cause the
economy to slow but higher prices might
also mean higher profits so it's a
little bit of a dance there in terms of
the actual impact and then obviously a
potential economic slowdown
um I'm calling it a Slowdown at this
point
I have not used the term recession
you'll see with the growth rates at this
point what we are anticipating is a
slowing of the economy we're not going
to maybe see the year over year growth
that we've seen over the past couple
years
um but at least at this point subject to
change not forecasting an actual
downturn in the revenue or in the growth
rates you will see ultimately when Chris
produces the worksheets you may see a
reduction in the revenue
um but that would be the result of the
tax law changes not necessarily a
reduction in in the actual base
looking at the chart or I'm sorry I
apologize represent all me oh no perhaps
Mr representative Roche or had to say I
apologize staring at the numbers
that doesn't matter I I just uh before
we go on too far I'm looking at the
factors consider I'm looking at your
ranges the zero to two percent I mean
that's
give me that that's a real big slowdown
I think I mean yeah that's reflective of
a pretty dramatic slowdown uh based on
what we've seen over the last few years
um correct and I understand the the
there's a lot of factors in there now
the things that you put in there as
factors to consider the impact of
inflation are you considering inflation
when you give us that maximum growth of
two percent
that is you know one of the one of the
things that kind of goes into the range
so I don't have a specific you know the
impact of inflation is X percent on the
growth rate but it is something that
we've considered as part of determining
the growth rate okay so it's not a
specific formula it's more just
informing the the ranges that we're
providing okay so the two percent is
factoring in already comprehensively
correct right my goal is to give you a
range that factors into you know
anticipated GDP growth
um the any influx effects of inflation
any historical trends that we've seen
and how business taxes operate so that
you have a range that kind of
encompasses all of that and you don't
need to necessarily parse out you know
we're going to do this because of
inflation and this percent because of
GDP my goal is to kind of get it all the
Easy Button into yes yes into a package
for you great thank you representative
alright do you have a question yeah just
briefly uh
commissioner when you said take into
consideration
it's all in my head
that's a rather nebulous terminology or
term uh I mean last month the uh in the
CPI was something like 6.7
um I think overall we're looking at
maybe eight or nine uh going towards ten
that devalues
the value of the dollar
yeah which then means
we got to spend more
together
when we're looking at budget estimates
and we're looking at a downturn that
it's got to happen sometime
um I mean how long have we've been
saying for about two years yeah more
than that yeah
um
yeah well it depends on the money market
who gives it and how many Monopoly
dollars are floating around it depends
on understand the question I'm getting
to Adam's here
what numbers should we look at the low
range is not a conservative number the
high range is not a con a liberal number
and vice versa
so
so again these are well two points one
these are our ranges that we feel are
reasonable at this point in time the
committee may feel differently and that
has has happened in the past you you may
decide that our ranges are too
optimistic and that maybe it's negative
two to two and maybe you go with
negative two we're just trying to
provide you our general feelings at this
point in time
to your earlier comment about inflation
you're correct we numbers are hovering
around six percent the latest
um release that came out it's down from
the eight to nine percent that we've
seen you know we've seen a number of
months of inflation but it's not
continuing to grow if the number that
came out in the last week or so was
showing 8 9 10 continued growing of
inflation this range might look
different we might say okay maybe it's
negative five maybe it's negative 10
because inflation doesn't seem to to be
under control we're at least seeing some
tempering of the inflation and
inflationary pressures it is not where
anyone wants it to be but it is not
continuing to grow if it was this range
might look different I guess is my point
representative ORS
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question how many years have
you been doing this
do you want the full you know
too many yes there you go that's good
enough for me thank you that's too many
or not that many
you've been at the dra what I've
essentially I've essentially been at the
dra since
um 2010 I took a brief Hiatus for about
18 months but I've essentially been at
the dra since August of 2010.
follow-up thank you madam chair so
having done the same work that you're
doing I have no doubt that you're you're
sure of what you're doing do you have
any doubts that you're sure of what
you're doing I'm sure that it's wrong
you got the job thank you
representative only
you haven't you've you've looked at New
Hampshire tax law changes you haven't is
there anybody that has tried to
summarize
the impact of the stimulus spending and
the tax changes at the federal level
so there's obviously Federal data for
that you know what the
OMB has estimated what the impact will
be
I think at this point my thought process
subject to criticism comment Etc is that
again we're trying to estimate fiscal
year 23 to then grow or decline for 24
and 25 and so a fair amount of the
stimulus money is in the economy and
therefore I believe in the revenues that
we've received in 22 and 23. if there
was a large you know
um
additional amount of stimulus that I
felt like had not been
working its way through the economy then
yes we may have wanted to make an
adjustment for that but thinking about
the base that we're trying to estimate
my feeling was that
either most of the money is in the
economy or some of it may already have
come out have already been spent but
there's more that's
um
the potential still to be spent and they
kind of would offset each other
that
kind of makes sense so again just trying
to think about what the base is I'm
looking at 22 and 23 do I feel like the
impact of the stimulus is probably in
the revenues
based on the growth we've seen in the
past couple years I would say yes you
know we saw
44.6 percent growth in 21 23 growth in
22 and we're seeing five percent growth
this year so that growth has started to
slow so that would kind of tell me the
majority of the impact of the stimulus
is felt in the revenues that we're using
as our base
so could I have a follow-up
yeah maybe it's because
I think
as much about the consumers that are
buying things in our economy as I do
about the companies on
is there
there isn't anything out there in the
literature about
um a negative effect of the removal of
the stimulus money we can look into that
first look at consumers but then also is
happening with the businesses
and some of the businesses on the edge
may not survive that
that certainly happened in the Great
Recession why it took so long to get out
of it yeah we'll do some research and
see if we if we can find any comments
about that that's a good point
Madam chair
um if it the committee would like I
could also ask Des Brian Gottlieb to
consider that question as well in their
presentation to you on the 28th
um they may actually have some other
information
um that may get Lindsay off the hook
I like how you think
Brian may not yeah
okay so looking at the chart on the
middle of the page
you'll see
a high low range for 23 you'll see an
impact of that 19.6 million in the tax
law changes resulting in a net range
at the bottom that's the same range that
shows on the prior Slide the net amount
is what we're showing on the prior slide
we then as we've already kind of or
actually I'll hold for one second
how did we come up with those ranges
so the low range takes actual
year-to-date revenue and then assumes
plan for the remainder of the year so
although we are significantly ahead of
plan to representative almi's point at
the beginning there is a chance that we
may start to see a Slowdown so let's say
okay take year-to-date revenue and let's
assume that slowdown let's just assume
we we're at plan for the rest of the
year
that's what produces the 1.2 billion
minus the 19.6 million arriving at the 1
billion 219 million five hundred
thousand
the high range
basically says take the first seven
months of the year and apply that 33.3
percent ahead of plan that we've been
year-to-date
let's assume we stay there for the rest
of the year so that the high essentially
assumes we don't see any slowing things
just kind of continue on the way they've
been happening for the first seven
months that produces the 1 billion 276
million seven hundred thousand minus the
19.6 million and the tax law changes
resulting in the 1 billion 257 million
one hundred thousand
so that's how we come up with the range
the low is essentially yep we're gonna
see some slowdown here the high says
nope we're just going to keep trekking
on the way we've been going
then it's we've already kind of talked
about we have a zero to two percent
growth rate for 25. again that's a
year-over-year growth rate so you would
apply that two percent say to the 23
amount and then you would apply the 25
two percent say to the 24 amount so
these are year-over-year growth rates
these are taking into accounts the
things that we've already talked about
and just the general prediction that GDP
growth is going to slow
um but
what we've seen is that the growth will
potentially remain positive and not yet
any estimates that it will slip negative
so we have the growth rates and then the
tax law changes for 24 and 25.
okay on to page four meals and rentals
tax
so year to date we are 50.6 or 33.5
percent ahead of plan for 6.4 million or
3.3 percent ahead of Prior year as
representative uluri mentioned earlier
remember when plan was done we're
significantly ahead of plan but plan was
done at a time when we were just coming
off of stay-at-home orders restaurant
closures Etc and we were anticipating if
those maintained that there would be a
significant impact to m r
however post-pandemic activity has shown
us that there was essentially pent-up
demand for dining out going on vacations
traveling as I've said before I think we
all realized how much we enjoyed eating
out when we couldn't eat out it's really
hard
um especially in my house with two
adults and two little kids to make three
meals a day at home so we certainly
realized that eating out is something
that we would like to do and have done
more of I think post pandemic because we
realize how important it is to us
um other things to consider transfers to
the municipal Revenue fund this is the
funds that we've talked about
in Prior presentations where 30 percent
of m r revenue is going into a dedicated
fund to go back to the municipalities
and also the school building Aid Debt
Service we provided the chart for how
that debt service is being paid out
through 2030.
so for fiscal year 23 this is an
instance where we are going to look at
the gross amounts and we would then
apply any growth rates to those gross
amounts so we're going to apply any
growth rates to the total revenue
collected before the transfer to the
municipal fund because it is revenue in
the door we're just going to send a
portion of it into a dedicated fund
so our estimates
[Music]
um
for 2023 gross amounts of
323.9 million to
455.5 million the reduction of the 128
million is the municipal Revenue
transfer plus the school building Aid
Debt Service arriving at the net of
295.9 million to
327.5 so the 295.9 and the 327.5 those
numbers are what you would compare to
plan because plan takes out the
municipal Revenue transfer those are
also the amounts that you would see in
the revenue Focus
because the revenue Focus amounts are
going to be net of those transfers
the low range assumes that m r performs
at plan for the last five months of 23
so we take year-to-date Revenue through
January and we assume plan for the
remaining five months similar to
business taxes although we are 33.5
percent ahead of plan
in the event that this economy does
start to slow there and there is an
impact to the meals and rentals tax or
the fact that prices are higher and
therefore people don't eat out or can't
afford to eat out or take vacations as
much
and or we see staffing issues
restaurants are not able to be open as
frequently or for as many hours as they
were previously
if all of those things kind of come
together we would see a slowing in the m
r tax for the remaining five months of
the year so that's what the low scenario
is assuming that we just meet plan for
the rest of the year and that slowing is
seen in the economy
Baha'i assumes that we remain
34.34 ahead of plan so the year-to-date
um growth over plan that we have seen
remains through the end of the year we
do not see any impact or any slowing as
a result of any of the the economy the
prices the Staffing Etc so that's how we
arrive at the range for 23.
representative do you have a question I
do thank you madam chair
um
not just meals on rentals tax but all of
them you apparently you don't take into
account inflation at all
we're going to again kind of take into
account inflation
as a result of the various scenarios
that we're looking at so inflation May
inform where we think the tax is going
to go but remember we are using as a
base Revenue year to date so there is
inflation already baked the impact of
inflation already baked into that
Revenue that we're using year to date as
the base so the only thing we really
need to account for is additional
impacts that we have not already seen
from inflation or other factors that we
may see in the last five months of the
year
so again not that we're not accounting
for it we just don't have a line item
that says inflation minus 5 million
actually it could go the other way could
it or it all it could because the prices
are higher it's a percent of meal prices
exactly exactly
so it's a positive until it reaches the
Tipping Point when prices get too high
the demand Falls
representative Ames
thank you thank you good morning
um
actually this may be a question more for
Chris uh
or other
senior gurus in our committee but uh
here with this presentation we are
seeing lows and highs in the end
at least historically we've had to
pick a number
so we've got to do
you know we've got to jump out on a limb
at zero percent or five percent we we
can't do that is that correct
that's correct representative Ames and
at the end of this process this
committee will come to some agreement on
a single number as your Revenue
projection for each of these taxes or
each of these Revenue sources
so that as the dra um is typically comes
in and presents a range because of I
think the types of questions that are
being asked the factors that you want to
consider when you're doing these
estimates be it inflation be it a
potential slowdown or recession be it
some sort of a boom because of a
stimulus so this committee will take all
that knowledge that you've been
presented through the economic briefings
and the agency presentations and you'll
come up with a single number that's your
best estimate or best guess as to what
the revenue will be in 24 and then again
in 25.
and you know do that based on your
adjustments for 23. so you often use
your 23 as your base number to kind of
grow into 24 and 25.
so what Lindsay's doing today is giving
you a range of numbers for each of these
Revenue sources
and telling her how telling you how she
got to those numbers with her team it's
up to the committee to decide whether
you want to stay within the within those
ranges go outside those ranges make
different assumptions
so that's a long-winded answer to I
think your question representative Ames
yeah so today we're just trying to get
inside the head of our expert and
understand where she's coming from but
then we will do our own discussion with
our expertise to see if we agree with
some of the assumptions or we're
slightly off from them oh great yeah and
representative Sanborn if I just might
as well the commissioner and her team or
some parts of her team will be available
as we move forward through this process
so as the committee gets to making some
of its final decisions if you want to
bounce questions off from dra to say
we're thinking this does that seem
reasonable with this Revenue stream you
can do that so you won't be in isolation
as well
representative Army
thank you and I think Beyond Beyond
sorry our personal expertise if we can
think
of questions like the one about
what is it going to do if the Consumer
Debt starts to slow down the spending on
and we can think of people outside of
this body that like Phil sletton as well
that may be able to find studies that
have are being done now that that could
help us try to triangulate down to
something that I don't think we're going
to be comfortable when we finish this I
don't think you ever are comfortable no
but this is the worst I think except for
the Great Recession when every year we
had to readjust the budget
and we've mentioned this previously that
the house is in the you know next
hardest position after the governor
because your base is the most uncertain
um so with every month that goes by it
gets a little bit easier because we get
further and further to knowing actual
revenues
um for 23 and the base
no 24.
representative spillsbury has a question
thank you madam chair
um I guess I'm going to make a couple of
observations and see whether you are in
concurrence more or less
taxes if you look across the board
greatly in their trend line relative to
the prior year and relative to the plan
but it strikes me as being an odd
coincidence
that our two biggest ones business taxes
and meals and rooms
both are essentially 33
and the third percent over plan
uh and I'm I guess the first question
from that observation is I
is that more than coincidence do we see
a correlation
that would tend to drive them ahead of
plan at the same rate but let me just go
to the second observation first
plan of course is just a measure of how
good we were at guessing two years ago
in the same process
and it's easy to get caught up in how
far over planned we are
and it seems like spectacular
performance but it may also be that we
just simply anticipated that downturn
that didn't materialize
what's probably much more important to
look at
is that business taxes are only 4.7
percent
ahead of Prior year
and meals and rooms tax serve two-thirds
of that at 3.3 percent had a prior year
so when we focus
on the the performance relative to Prior
year
it mitigates that impression of
spectacular Revenue growth or
performance
and it's not difficult to see
that if the downturn finally does come
and parenthetically it seems to me that
the Federal Reserve is virtually
committed in getting us there
uh it doesn't take much of a downward
adjustment
to move to zero to two or zero to five
percent
um so I I don't find your
your estimates of growth
um
to be wildly optimistic I think they're
very realistic and could even be a
little lower
to your first point about
um business taxes being 33.3 ahead of
plan and m r being 33.5 percent ahead of
plan I triple checked that number
because I was like it must be a typo so
I noticed the same thing you did I have
not wrapped my head around
whether or not there is any correlation
between the two I I think it may just be
a coincidence
um
in terms of your comment about the
deviation from plan versus the deviation
from prior year you were correct that
um the the deviation from plan was due
to a cautious Revenue estimating process
during a time of a lot of uncertainty
two years ago
if you I believe if my memory serves me
correctly if you look back to revenue
estimating
prior to covid you wouldn't see these
sorts of deviations typically Revenue
estimates or revenues perform much much
closer to plan if you saw deviations
like this it would be because of a
significant tax change that hadn't been
accounted for in plan or something like
that so typically and maybe this is just
optimistic memory but I believe we tend
to be a lot closer between actuals and
plan it's really just a sign of the
times and what we were all going through
at that point and not wanting to
overestimate revenues during a time when
we could potentially see see a downturn
it's you always want the estimates to be
correct but if if you have to be wrong
many cases it's it's better to be a
little bit more conservative than overly
optimistic
um especially with revenues
representative fellows
thank you madam chair
so if if we go back and if we look at at
estimates that were made you know for
the last
12 years or 10 10 years before covid at
that time inflation was quite low it was
like one to two you know two percent a
year
and then you know during for the last
two years we've been dealing with
significant inflation
and that's not gonna it's not gonna shut
off
so can you help me understand how
how your estimates are impacted or are
not reflecting
what I believe is is that inflation I
think it's going to go down but I think
it's going to be well above two percent
which it would have been kind of what
was going on up until
um
the prior estimates were made
so I again I think the thing to remember
is you're using a base of fiscal 23
Revenue year to date
so again to the extent that inflationary
impacts are showing in that Revenue
you're accounting for it in your
estimates
the times when you need to account for
inflation or any other changes the tax
law changes being a good example is when
that impact is not in your current
revenues so where we've seen now to your
point
Rising inflation over a period of time
it's not like it just started last month
if anything hopefully we've reached the
peak and we're going down
it is likely accounted for in the
revenues that we're using as the base
so I don't think I don't think you need
to worry that it inflation was different
10 years ago
because that's not impacting the revenue
estimating you're doing now if if I said
okay your growth rate should be the same
as it was 10 years ago then you might
have a point well ten years ago you
didn't have inflation the same
inflationary pressures so that's not a
good comparison that would be
something to consider
but the fact that inflation didn't exist
at the same levels 10 years ago where
we're using year-to-date revenue and
we're projecting the remainder of the
year
I think we just need to think about how
inflation is going to change between now
and the end of the year or how inflation
is going to change between this fiscal
year and next fiscal year I don't think
it matters what it was 10 years ago
because that's 10 years ago is not at
the moment informing anything that's
driving the estimates here
representative Southworth
thank you for taking my question comment
as you look at the 33 It just strikes me
that those two areas meals and room and
business tax affect almost every single
consumer in terms of spending whereas a
lot of the others are much narrower and
maybe due to anomalies or other kinds of
things
um you know like something like tobacco
everyone doesn't participate in but
correct as you said I think both could
be uh pent-up demand sure
I I agree with with your comment where
my mind kind of went first is knowing
based on the information we presented
um earlier this week and at prior
presentations the majority of our
business tax revenue is kind of paid by
a few number of very large multinational
corporations
um those are not the same
taxpayers as the meals and rentals tax
but I hadn't gone the level further that
you just brought up which is consumers
are actually at the bottom of both of
those I was thinking you know Acme
Corporation very large multinational
corporation versus your neighborhood
pizza shop there was a those are not the
same
but at the bottom are consumers buying
products from Acme or services and
buying pizzas at the pizza shop so yes I
agree with your point
representative Ulrich
acne Staples in Franklin is a large
multinational I get it we got to come up
with a name that we all know is just me
making up
it's not a real taxpayer
okay
so that's how we came up with our low
and high so again we assumed m r might
start to temper a little bit that we
would just be at plan for the rest of
the year versus kind of continuing the
growth that we've seen year to date
and then we're looking at between a zero
and five percent growth for 24 and again
for 25.
for 24 that zero percent kind of assumes
that the impact of inflation and or
slowing of the economy does keep in keep
m r flat to represent a plett's point
earlier where inflation drives prices to
a point the demand starts to decrease
because obviously to a point higher
prices just produces higher tax revenue
but if we get to a point where that
starts to impact demand
we would see m r kind of remain flat and
then the high just kind of assumes that
we keep
um trekking along and we continue to see
increases generally consistent where
we're seeing uh true representative
spillsbury's Point what we're seeing
compared to Prior year right so not what
we're seeing compared to plan but we're
about three percent ahead of Prior year
and so our high assumes that we continue
on that Trend if not a little bit more
and then for 25 again that zero to five
percent growth rate
pre-pandemic MNR generally grew around
five percent a year so five percent is
kind of a historic growth rate for m r
so the 25 growth rate kind of returns to
a more normal year-over-year growth but
obviously on this new
um base Revenue that we've seen
okay
page five tobacco taxes
so fiscal year to date we are 12.8
million or 8.9 percent below plan
or 8.9 million or 6.3 percent below
prior year this really is the result of
a decline in our tobacco tax stamp sales
those are the stamps that go on the
packages of cigarettes
other tobacco products that portion
um of the revenue is growing but is a
much smaller portion of Revenue than
tobacco tax than tobacco stamp sales
the other thing to consider is a ban on
mentholated products and other flavored
tobacco products like we've seen in
Massachusetts that has kind of driven at
least at some point an increase in our
Revenue here in New Hampshire as people
came across the border
um
to buy those products if other bands
like that continue that could impact
revenues in a positive way if we see a
ban at the federal level that would
obviously have a negative impact
for our 23 range it's 217 to
222.8 million the low assumes that our
fiscal year to date percentage of 6.3
percent below prior year we just
maintain that for the rest of the year
our high assumes that we have actual
year-to-date Revenue but for the
remainder of the year we actually equal
prior year so that the the decline that
we've seen over prior year kind of stops
and we rebound a little bit that's how
we get to the range the range is
relatively small for this tax it might
be a welcome
um observation for folks as your
thinking about how you're going to go
through this process
in terms of 24 and 25 growth rates we
have a minus five percent to zero
percent growth rate for 24.
um historic year rear reductions in
cigarette stamp sales due to cessation
efforts this is kind of a normalizing of
the
um tobacco tax stamp sales
normalizing from the the covet levels
that we saw where a lot of people
um did not stop smoking during covid if
anything we saw a lot of rates
increasing across the country so the
minus five percent to zero kind of
assumes
that we start to see those secession
cessation efforts increase again with a
little bit of the tempering of the
increase in the other tobacco products
and then 25 we're saying minus three to
zero folks that have been on this
committee for a while will know minus
three percent year-over-year growth is
kind of the historic Trend with Tobacco
on average we do see a year-over-year
decline in tobacco as people stop
smoking but again if they switch to you
know e-cigarettes
um we will pick up a little bit of
revenue from that but again the majority
of the revenue is driven by the stamp
sales so when those go down the revenue
goes down
representative Ames you're just a minor
question but what what is the revenue
that E-cigarettes are producing
hold on I'm having a chart I have it
visually but I need just want to check
and see if I have the number for you if
not we can get that
foreign
so e-cigarettes in fiscal year 21 in
total produced 5 million dollars of
Revenue
in 22 we saw 7.9 million in Revenue
um and year-to-date through December we
saw 22 increase over last year so so
e-cigarette revenue is increasing but
again you know you're looking at
seven million dollars out of
220 million dollars so it is it's
increasing but it's a very small portion
of the revenue
follow up and then representative Oliver
after that yeah
um
so that's interesting and that
shows that this new brand of uh
nicotine is popular or is selling anyway
um and the revenue is positive unlike
cigarettes correct and um
yet it's very small but I suppose it
could expand is there anything else that
is moving in the up Direction rather
than in the other tobacco products
category I guess
I would say the I mean there at least 21
to 22 the majority of the increase in
other tobacco products was driven by
e-cigarettes the remainder of OTP was
relatively flat so it really is
e-cigarettes
um and E-cigarettes are not taxed the
same way as cigarettes are so in
if there was a world where everybody
that stopped smoking shifted to
e-cigarettes so if you didn't smoke
cigarettes anymore but everyone shifted
to e-cigarettes and E-cigarettes were
taxed exactly the same way as cigarettes
were you wouldn't see an impact to the
revenue right but because some people do
just quit
you see a reduction and then the people
that do switch over to e-cigarettes
because the tax rate is not comparable
you do see that reduction in tax
uh thank you
um
I've been sitting next to this guy for
too long
you've stimulating thought
when we're talking about e-cigarettes or
other tobacco products we've got a
competitor to the South uh that
continually raises rates
how of our sales gone according to their
rate increases or does your department
even bother with that
I would say we haven't tracked it or
correlated it specifically but when we
do see the rate increases around all of
our neighboring states New Hampshire has
by far the lowest tax rate out of all of
the New England states New York New
Jersey et cetera so anytime their rates
increase
um we see an increase in our sales when
our when Massachusetts straight up
banned the menthol cigarettes we saw a
significant increase in those products
purchased here in New Hampshire so there
is definitely an impact
on any bans increases in tax changes Etc
okay thank you and for the record I take
my nicotine in eggplant parmesan
Southwest thank you for follow-up I
think in your other presentation you
actually told us the percent that we're
out of state uh for the tobacco tax we
yes there are there are studies done by
the tax Foundation you're correct we did
provide that information
um so we know how much is moving out of
state
um you know cigarettes purchase here
that are consumed out of state I just
don't know you know if Massachusetts
raises their tax rate by five percent
what is the increase or change here in
New Hampshire
sure
representative
thank you madam chair I'm not sure this
is within your purview we'll try
but I wonder whether New Hampshire
specifically has done any um studies
about the impact of the cost of health
care for uh tobacco use and the change
in those costs relative to the lower use
of tobacco sure I don't have that
information
um but there I'm sure there are
organizations tobacco-free kids is one
that comes to mind other groups that may
may have that information specifically
thank you thank you madam chair
okay good and tobacco hey interest in
dividends tax on Page Six
fiscal year to date we're basically
right at plan where the 300 000 or 0.6
below print plan or 8.8 million or 14.9
below prior year IND is a tax that can
have year-over-year swings
um stock market performance interest
rates distribution of profits all of the
things that we talked about in our prior
presentations can drive IND Revenue
um and then I mentioned the effect of
the tax law changes because the rate is
decreasing and again just as a reminder
um you're in a tough place because the
majority of IND revenue does not come in
until April so you're you're attempting
to forecast Revenue at a time where we
haven't even probably seen half of the
amount that we're going to get for the
year so
um it's not the easiest tax at this
point in the year to estimate
in terms of a low for 23 we assume that
the seven percent
um
sorry the 14.9 percent that we are below
prior year will be maintained through
the rest of the year and then we take
out the 6.3 million for the rate
reduction that we anticipate will impact
our revenues in April and in June
and then for the high we assume
year-to-date revenue and then we just
add the remaining five months of last
year so we essentially assume that the
reduction that we've seen to Prior year
will go away and we'll see
um revenues equal prior year in the last
five months and again we subtract the
rate reduction so you'll see on a net
basis this range is
126.9 million to
141.3 million so again
15 million dollar range for this year
that range will obviously tighten once
we get more revenue for IND but again
just the impact of the fact that we
don't have the majority of the revenue
received yet
representative Ellery
in our neighbors to the South have got a
new tax that they put in they do
um I'm not sure how you would track that
except by new IND taxpayers
correct and we wouldn't have that
information yet
[Music]
because the IND returns that we are
going to receive in April will be for
the tax year ending 12 31
22. so it'll be prior to the
millionaires tax if you will in
Massachusetts going into account into
effect but that is something that we can
certainly track we can look at
um new new taxpayers
it would seem to me that we would before
this uh tax disappears and you're no
longer tracking it we would have two
good years of data to show I would at
least yeah yep thank you yes
representative Phyllis thank you madam
chair I need some help understanding
what these different taxes are and
including the one you I I don't
understand how the Millionaire's tax in
Massachusetts would impact New Hampshire
so there's an increased taxes
millionaires tax in New Hampshire is an
additional income tax on top of the
amount that's already paid for those
High net worth individuals I believe
representative uluri's point is to the
extent that those individuals decide to
move to New Hampshire where we have no
broad-based income tax and our tax is
only on interest and dividends that
would be a significant tax savings
potentially to those individuals and so
we may see some people move to New
Hampshire in order to avoid that
additional tax burden in Massachusetts
so so the main part of my question was
help me understand what the ones that
are in this I'm looking at the top of
the page and it tells me the percentage
that are from taxable annuities
which I I think I know what those are
but I'm not sure actual cash and
property distributions is that that's
like one big category
correct and that tell me what all of
those things are that tracks back to the
slides that we've presented in Prior
presentations where we break down the
percent of interest in dividends revenue
between interest dividends and
distributions and we're kind of showing
over time how the percent that was
attributable to interest has kind of
decreased in recent years where the
percent attributable to distributions
has increased so those are kind of the
main categories of Revenue that make up
the interest in dividends tax
so I you have to explain what what our
actual cash and property distribution or
give me an example so to the extent that
an individual receives a distribution
um from a corporation that it's taxable
under the interest and dividends tax
similar to if you received a dividend or
interest income on you know bank
accounts those are all things that are
taxable under the interest and dividends
tax and you will see the last point or
the last item mentioned here the 7.3
percent federal tax exempt interest
income there is interest income that is
tax that is tax exempt under the federal
level that is taxable here in New
Hampshire bonds
um it's a variety of things we can
provide you with additional information
on that there's a whole checklist that's
on our website of the various components
that fall under the interest and
dividends tax
representative ulery I think yeah just
to follow up on that that would include
the rmds that uh
certain people receive from their
Pension funds the required minimum
distribution potentially and but then
there's a threshold in New Hampshire so
if you get less than that you don't pay
the tax but if you get more than that
then you have to pay the tax on
everything over that so if you're one of
the
um numerous now uh very wealthy people
that have Pension funds or
um
well yeah I don't want to use the
derogatory tone pension fund babies but
trust fund babies rather they uh they
have to take some money
and then
yes to a degree but the amount of money
that you take out of and that is is this
as an example but it you have to meet
the threshold first and uh We've set the
Threshold at the threshold is twenty
four hundred dollars for a single filer
or 4 800 for joint filers and then
there's various exemptions as well so if
you're over 65 if you're blind if you're
disabled before your 65th birthday etc
those are all exemptions that are
available in the tax as well
representative only
yes on where can we find a definition of
distribution as versus dividend we can
get that to you again there's a
checklist that's available
um in the instructions for our forums so
we can we can provide that to give
additional clarity
and we can certainly ask maybe if we
have the CPA Society or some of those
folks come back and flesh out some of
these things for us we can do that any
other questions right now
okay
defines it out true but if you want more
practical real world you know how is
this impacting New Hampshire people I
think maybe the accountants would be
able to or maybe ask your own accountant
um sure that would be helpful okay
um so once we have the range for 23 we
have um growth rates again for 24 and 25
we're looking at zero to two percent in
each year
um again this tax can fluctuate over
time
um this one is a bit hard as I mentioned
at this point in the year to estimate
um but we're essentially showing flat or
minimal growth and then you will see the
22.2 million in 24 and the 23.4 million
in 25 that is the result of the decrease
in the tax rate
so those are tax law changes change
impacts
okay moving on page seven communication
Services tax
fiscal year to date were five and a half
million or 24.1 million below plan
um we are 0.6 million or 3.4 percent
below prior year
we've talked about this tax before but
increased use of video conferencing
decreased use of VoIP or traditional
landlines or telephones and then shifts
in the allocation of building for what
billing for Wireless plans from voice to
data those are all things that impact
CST
for 23 we have a pretty tight range
we're looking at 28.8 million to 29.9
million
the low estimate assumes that we receive
2.3 million a month for the remainder of
the Year why 2.3 million that is the
most common amount that we have received
in recent times for a monthly Revenue
amount so if you told me today how much
if you asked me today how much revenue
do you think you're going to receive for
CST this month I would say 2.3 million
so we take that amount and we just plug
it in for the rest of the year
and the high assumes that our sustaining
percent compared to Prior year is
maintained through the end of the year
this tax we have a negative growth rate
minus three percent to zero that's just
generally the trend that we've been
seeing with this tax again it's a
relatively small tax relatively small
range that we're looking at for
CSD
representative Ames
on the increased use of video
conferencing which I guess is mostly
Zoom or that kind of thing
um what's what are the figures there
I don't have those
um readily available because there is
not a specific line on the CST return
for video conferencing versus landline
telephone versus Wireless talk
um so the extent that you have a
provider that is
um performing any number of those
Services the amount is kind of all
bundled together
so I don't have a breakout for each of
those Individual Services unfortunately
it would just it's more anecdotal as the
result of audits and reviews of tax
returns that we've done
um and
um I'm wondering about to other people
who should be paying or not paying is
that an issue uh because this is sort of
Novel and uh maybe unknown or maybe it's
purposeful I don't know we have Auditors
that are assigned to this this tax who
do reach out to businesses and um who
operate in this Communications world to
make sure that they are collecting and
remitting the tax
representative homie
thank you on the shift in allocation of
building billing of Wireless plans from
voice to data on
do you
it seems to me that when you look into
that it when at least when I've drilled
down six layers in Comcast spill to find
how much I'm paying for voice that
on they have shifted
a lot more voice costs a awful lot less
according to them than it used to do
correct and that on they've been doing
that ever since
since they started combining into to
Cable plus Everything Burns uh so do you
are you able do you try to contest with
them
in terms of what they're actually
charging for voice sure so you're
correct that the bundling of charges
right so voice and data oh you can have
your home phone and your cable and your
internet access all on one bill and
here's one amount right that then needs
to be split so that we know what portion
and the provider knows what portion is
um relative to voice and therefore
subject to the tax
um
it is difficult at times to see how that
breakdown is done on your bill and
you're correct that as time has gone on
um people or the the allocation is less
towards voice and more towards internet
access cable Etc
um we do audit we do engage in
discussions with the providers about the
amount that they're allocating between
those various buckets
and do you get anywhere it depends
representative fellows are are there
rules that govern how they do their
allocation not necessarily
um so the the Only Rule really that
we're following is that internet access
is not subject to tax under the CST and
cannot be subject to tax under CST so
the portion that is data is not CST but
how they decide to allocate is really to
a large extent up to them we can
challenge them on their reasonableness
of that allocation if it were to say
nothing is voice yet you're providing a
landline that wouldn't be reasonable so
that's where the kind of the
negotiations come in but there's nothing
that says certain amounts have to go
into each bucket
yes Phillip so are are there actual
um regulations or rules that cover the
communications tax
their statute and rules that cover it
yes statutes and rules yep okay
okay under does it come under Department
of Revenue Administration okay thanks
yeah and we would be the committee that
would make those
determinations if we wanted to change
the law okay anything else
okay
page eight real estate transfer tax
so fiscal year to date we are 28.6
million or 23.8 percent ahead of plan or
2.8 million or 1.8 percent below prior
year so to represent a spillsbury's
earlier Point again plan assumed
um a real decline in the real estate
market after we kind of saw a covid boom
where a lot of people were moving to New
Hampshire
um so that's why we're so far ahead of
plan but we are you know basically flat
with with prior year
fiscal year-to-date amounts are net of a
five million dollar transfer to the
affordable housing fund that occurs in
October of each year so we will estimate
the gross grow the gross amount and then
subtract the five million dollars
because the five million dollars is
money that we receive it just goes into
a dedicated fund
things to consider mortgage rates of
increase as we know median sale prices
do remain high however the inventory is
slowing significantly
um cost of building supplies and just
the fact that homes are quite difficult
to afford for many people at this point
the real estate market Peak was likely
seen earlier this year we have seen a
decline in the real estate transfer tax
in January and February year-to-date
amounts are showing a decline as well
and I'll talk about those when we talk
about the ranges for 23.
but I'll pause for a second before I do
this I see Hands representative ulery
yeah just following up on your your
comments about the the the percentage
decrease with the reevaluation that took
place
that means that
a 25 uh 25 uh 250 000 home is now worth
roughly
275 300 000 uh in broad spectrum sure
which then inflates this number
but nothing has changed
right regarding the housing market this
is all an inflationary number
potentially so when we talk about Rhett
remember we're going to talk about the
number of transactions right you need
the sales to occur in order to collect
the tax
but you can have fewer sales at a much
higher value much higher amount and
still see the tax either stay the same
or increase and so to your point as as
the values get driven up you don't need
as many sales to generate the same
amount of Revenue what we're likely
starting to see is that the number of
sales just is not enough anymore to keep
the revenue increasing those values have
gotten too high other pressures have
really cooled the real estate market and
so you need both the sale and the value
but when they both start to have a
negative impact then the tax will fall
I think I saw you representative plett
and then we'll go to representative
Southworth yeah uh this is one I'm more
pessimistic than you are for Real Estate
transfer attacks because the market
rank considerably in the in the last few
months within higher interest rates the
start to reflect a little bit in the
price of homes just a little bit but the
slowdown in sales has been huge we'll
talk about that in in a minute I I agree
with you I may be cautiously optimistic
for a couple of reasons and I'll talk
about when we get to the ranges
Ruby and self-rath
um just to correct myself is this mainly
connect um collected at the county level
but you can see the communities where
the properties were sold so you can do
it both ways correct so the
representative Southworth is correct
this tax is collected by the counties at
the time that they put the stamp on your
tax deed
um or your transfer deed and then they
remit it to us on a monthly basis so we
know the amount for each County so we
can look at County to County comparison
which we've done in some prior
presentations
we can we can
representative all me
do
do we
um
do we know on whether
the people who are really afraid of uh
large corporations coming in and buying
up a lot of Housing and then turning it
into high-level rentals that used to be
for the residents on if that is actually
not happening in New Hampshire at all I
don't have any information on that on
the realtors association might that's
not any data that we would have but I I
have heard that concern as well if that
concern was correct and it may be that
New Hampshire's Market is not terribly
attractive at National levels but on
that would be a counter effect correct
which I wouldn't want
representative Phyllis so I'm I one of
the things like you would track on the
municipal level would be the number of
building permits issued is do you are
you taking
um that into account so we don't have
data for this specific number of
building permits issued but you know
when you see cost of building supplies
um that just the number of new builds
that's something anecdotally that we
hear about in the market and certainly
if Builders are not building new homes
then those sales cannot occur so it's
definitely something I think that is
impacting Rhett
um but we again don't have that specific
building permit data it's more just
anecdotal from what we're hearing
representative Olney
could I just add to that that
building permits per se are not a very
good indicator at this point we've lost
at least 40 percent of the builders that
we're going to build that had permits in
the last six months
so your point being that the permit may
be pulled but the build may never happen
yeah I see okay
okay so range for fiscal year 23.
so the low
assumes that fiscal year-to-date Revenue
through Monday so taking basically as
much revenue as we can
um
is 3.4 percent below prior year and so
we assume that that's going to be
maintained through the rest of the year
so we have as I mentioned seen a decline
compared to Prior year in both January
and now February revenues and so we're
kind of assuming that that we are on the
downward Trend and that remains through
the rest of the year the high assumes
that the fiscal year-to-date percentage
that we saw at the end of December which
was a 5.4 percent increase over prior
year is maintained through the rest of
the year so at the end of December we
were 5.4 percent ahead of Prior year but
through Monday we were 3.4 percent below
so that's the kind of shift that we
think we're seeing
the reason why I included the amounts
through December as the high option is
because January and February tend to be
very low ret months anyway it's you know
not a lot of people are searching for
homes around the holidays it's the dead
of winter maybe you're looking for a ski
condo but you know for a lot of people
it's not the time of year that they come
looking to buy a beautiful lake house
for instance so I'm cautiously
optimistic that the decline that we see
in January and February is really just a
normal decline it's a normal slowing
that happens this time of year
and that it may be by taking the
year-to-date data through Monday maybe a
little bit too optimistic so that's why
I gave kind of both options
um the range is again still relatively
tight 225 million to 232 million
for 24 and 25 we assume 24 will be a
negative five percent to zero growth so
we do we are assuming that we have seen
a peak and we are going to decline
um but then 25 is negative two percent
to two percent negative 2 to positive
two
um that assumes that we may continue to
decline from our Peak but also you know
anecdotally we are hearing there are
people that do want to buy houses
um they're waiting for the market to
cool they're waiting for those prices to
come down so those prices come down and
the Tran the volume of transaction goes
up that's okay that might produce growth
because the prices are so high they can
come down as long as the transactions
are happening we could still see growth
so that's how we kind of get to the
minus two to positive 2 in 25.
okay
last one utility property tax on page
nine
we are one hundred thousand or half a
percent ahead of plan we're basically
right on plan for the year we are
slightly below prior year at two hundred
thousand or just under one percent
um we can see fluctuations in property
value new taxable property can be
destructed constructed and to the extent
that taxpayers have a credit
um on file they can utilize those
credits and that can impact the revenues
our range for upt for 23 is 40.7 million
to 44.9
the low is actual year to date with plan
for the remainder of the year and the
high assumes year-to-date uh Revenue
with sustaining percent versus prior
year maintained through the end of the
year
growth range small
zero to three percent
um this tax performs pretty consistently
around the 40 to 45
million dollar range so I'm not a lot of
fluctuation in this tax from year to
year
questions represent ullery
did you say you just mentioned not a lot
of change yeah a lot of change has taken
place the
uh I forget the name of the Northeast
sustainability project or whatever it's
called
um changing the size of the cables
they're going up which should have uh
increased the par the upt substantially
because a 10 kilowatt or kilovolt cable
is this big and the other one's this big
um
that's a good point I guess my point is
maybe as overall the taxes is fairly
consistent in 40 to 45 million but the
tax is made up of a variety of entity
types or utility types right so you may
see one entity type that has an increase
in value while another entity or another
utility type is falling in value so you
know if I'm not saying that every
utility utility property every year is
seeing the same value but as a whole the
values have been roughly consistent year
to year but yes you can see individual
fluctuations based on the type of
utility or service that they're
providing
representative almi
thank you I thought
that I remembered that the
utility property tax is based on
assessments that are done every year
from the dra on and that it's relatively
easy to track especially this late in
the year
how much is actually going to come in so
at this point in the year
um generally yes we have issued our
values we determine the values for all
these utilities so we know what Revenue
should come in based on on our
assessments every year we have a number
of utilities that challenge those values
that appeal those values and so we have
to work through that appeal process so
that's kind of what we're getting at
with the credits
um that sort of thing if so that's some
way that the fluctuation exists and why
we don't always know exactly the amount
of money that we will bring in about
um 11 12 difference
thank you representative fellows did you
still have a question
I was going to try to look it up but
what exactly what is covered by the
utility tax obviously polls and so it's
it's all utility property
um the rate is six dollars and sixty
cents per thousand dollars of value we
determine the value as representative
Ami mentioned at the dra so it's
everything from hydroelectric dams
um to your large
um you know generation facilities
to gas pipelines any sort of utility
value
or utility property excuse me
representative plut yes how do you set
that value is it a combination of
netbook and replacement or whatever tell
me correct it can depend on the utility
and the the area that they operate in
the utilities in May of every year
provide us
um with their financial information and
we use that financial information to
come up with the values whether we use
Netbook book discounted cash flow Etc
the combination can depend on the type
of utility but we value each utility
individually
yes uh if you have a
two billion dollars on a plant
but it's not producing a kilowatt hour
because it's not competitive what's the
value so the potential for Revenue to be
generated is part of what goes into the
value which is why we have the utilities
provide us with their financial
information so we do take that into
account in the values
representative Schamberg thank you madam
chair thank you for taking this question
uh you say they send your reports do you
do actual visual
uh assessments going out
not unless sometimes the utilities ask
us to come and view
um especially during uh maybe an appeal
of their valuation but typically we
would use the information the financial
information and other information that's
provided to us so we do not go out and
visually inspect every year but um from
time to time we will go out and visit
representative already has a question on
the statement first in that question
um this committee worked very very hard
to take the evaluation of the utilities
away from local properties because we
had a situation in New Hampshire where
town a was valuing a telephone pole that
costs twenty six thousand dollars to put
in some of them were charging twenty six
thousand dollars a year for the poll and
the town a hundred yards away over the
Town Line was charging zero so we
leveled it out that's one thing uh so
that everyone understands the
second issue is you're doing property
this is a property evaluation
they have an appeal to you to determine
whether you did or do they have an
appeal to the land use Court
so they have an appeal to us first if
they're not satisfied with the results
here then they can go to the board of
tax and land appeals or to Superior
Court
and that's how it works for all of our
taxpayers if you appeal a business tax
assessment you start with our
Administrative Hearings process within
dra which yes sits at dra but we work
very hard to keep them walled off
um and then if you're not satisfied
there then you have the opportunity to
proceed
new Superior Court judge on land use is
approved
another field of expertise needs to be
added to his resume
with our purview so I cannot answer that
question however representative
Schamberg has a question if I could
interrupt for just one minute just to
address representative uluri's point
about the local values so the dra your
correct assesses the utility property
value for all of the utilities in the
state some municipalities utilize our
values others decide to assess their own
values and use their own contract
assessor or in-house assessor to perform
that work you mentioned earlier this
week the work that representative abrami
did with a commission that developed HB
700 commission
that was to make the valuation of
transmission facilities
or transmission property uniform
there was additional work done that is
still in a study committee I believe to
look at making the valuation of
generation and
distribution I might be mixing up
distribution and transmission but anyway
to make that more uniform that work
hasn't concluded yet but so you can
still see different values from town to
town and Between the States state and
the municipalities in those areas but
good memory
thank you madam chair uh uh just
in the dra does
Town evaluations of real estate
properties right every year we review
the reassessments and reappraisals that
are done in the municipalities and we
ensure that the municipalities are
meeting the Constitutional requirement
to fully reevaluate all property every
five years
but we don't actually do the work the
work is done at the Town level
we just monitor it representative yes
this utility property tax
is passed on to electric rate payers
right so it's paid by rate payers likely
it's likely that the business passes
that on that that is something that
could happen yes
representative Phillips
uh thank you is this utility tax is this
the tax that was developed in
conjunction with the education lawsuit
or that is before my time but to your
point this tax goes 100 into the
education trust fund so these utilities
do not pay at this local level they do
not pay the Statewide education property
taxes because that's that's where it
came from okay thank you 20 years ago
representative Bowman
thank you it was part of the original
education funding plan
and it went in there and got forgotten
representative Britain
I think Madam chair so regarding the um
assessment uh I know we were involved in
a a rather large uh lawsuit by two
generators
um and we had a an assessor that most of
the other towns that already had as well
and apparently he didn't do a very great
job on on doing that we ended up like
with a multi-town
um settlement so that was simply because
we ignored the assessments that dra did
yes so municipalities have the option to
use our assessed value for the utility
property tax
[Music]
um
many towns do not
in general
the amounts that are the assessed value
amounts that are determined by a
contract assessor or a local assessor
employed by the town that the
municipality may use they tend to be
higher than the amounts that the dra has
determined so there's pluses and minuses
to to that
thank you I would say there's a lot of
minuses actually
they put an r in your name for some
reason I've been saying it wrong I
apologize
any other questions right now
representative this covers more than
just electric facilities does it not
does the planet of gas as well correct
and anything else correct yep gas
electric transmission generation coal
generation nuclear
um but gas you said gas pipelines yep
gas as well okay and any other form of
energy
wind
yep yep
one more apologize representative Army
sorry thank you on solar is there a
floor on on
when you have to start paying that so it
would just be very large solar
um
I don't know the answer to that at the
time somebody with it on their rooftop
it would not be it would not be someone
with it on their rooftop they would it
would need to be a larger scale but I
can find out for you
the answer to that
okay any other
okay last page page 10 it's just a
summary of everything that we went
through
so it's One Stop Shop to look at the dra
high and lows for 23 and then the high
and low growth ranges for 24 and 25 so
it's really just meant to be a reference
for you we talked about all the
difficult stuff
excellent presentation we have a lot to
think about I'm sure we'll have
questions but thank you this is very
easy for me to read at least and I
learned a lot so thank you okay we can
take a break I think Chris want to come
back at one that works for me okay you
can start with the worksheet I can go
over what that the function of that will
be for this committee
um and maybe there's some taxes or some
revenues we can discuss as maybe getting
done today that would be a good thing
about fish and game and Highway funds
since those tend to be two of the
revenue areas that come last let's get
them out of the way first
um so we have a sense of arrangement
today we can check something off the
list is that the goal and swept I think
maybe swept might be another one we
could address today you'll have to help
me understand parliamentarian do we just
do straw votes at this point or do we
actually have to go into an executive
session or there's no executive session
necessary it's just if the committee can
come to a straw poll agreement we'll put
the whatever you agree to we'll put into
the resolution
that this committee will look at make
sure it's what you've all agreed to and
then you move forward to the full full
floor okay oh representative what are
you saying are budgets based on straw
I am not
question oh representative aim sorry
sorry just uh
what is your plan for the rest of the
day time
I think we had planned to go from like
one to 2 30 ish does that sound it
depends on how long the committee wants
to stay I'll be giving you either
worksheet it's going to be really driven
by where you're ready to do some of the
work in deciding some of the revenues
how does that sound one to two thirty
sound reasonable try to get something
done yeah yes representative spilsbury
is it an option to just carry on and
break by 130.
perfect so no
hey that's just my vote what do you guys
think do you want to keep going and we
could just take a five minute bathroom
break or do you want to take lunch for
half an hour tell me well I was gonna
say about the other straw polls work
well but they might work well right this
moment right absolutely
tell me your thoughts folks about 12 30
to 2.
come back at 12 30 and go to 2 or 1 30.
thank you
all right so the sensim hearing is that
lunch is actually important and we'll
come back at one and we'll go to 2 or 2
30 depending on how we feel but no later
everybody agree to that raise your hand
uh anyone opposed to that raise your
hand
okay I think we have consensus
great
see you back at one
foreign
thank you
I can't
good afternoon good afternoon
what's that
okay
welcome back Chris Shea is going to lead
us through his worksheets
jumping right in huh
so everybody should have a document that
looks like this in front of them
basically the organization sheet for
this committee
so each time start after today each time
this committee meets and makes decisions
I'll update this document and then
you'll get a new version of it
the version will be sent to you
electronically as well as I'll provide
the hard copies
and it will also be available on our
website every
piece of information that has come
through the to this committee related to
revenues so all the economic briefings
all the agency presentations that you've
heard over the last couple of weeks all
that information has been loaded onto
our website so if you're remembering or
recalling you know an agency said X in
their presentation but you can't put
your hands on your paper copy it is on
our website and I'll send the link out a
little later again today just to remind
people
this doesn't say Millions I assume it is
though
excuse me act to what what's your the
numbers
so pay if you look right on the front
page
right at the bottom it says in millions
I'll increase the font if you would like
you were cheating and going ahead
so the document's broken into basically
three sections you get your general fund
and education trust funds your Highway
funds and your fish and game funds that
this committee is responsible for
providing unrestricted Revenue estimates
for
the most of the play occurs in the
general funds in the education trust
fund that's where there's I would say a
little bit more debate a little bit more
questions
um so if you turn to page three
you're going to see across the top
you'll see column headings A B C D and
just above that you'll see gen ETF
that's just telling you that that
Revenue source
where it's deposited
so if it's the business taxes it goes to
the general fund and the education trust
fund for the work you're doing at the
start of this process you don't have to
be concerned with that you're just
coming up with a total number
once you guys have some estimates made
I'll do a split into those various funds
and then provide back to you you know
how much is going to education trust
fund how much is going to the general
fund
when you do your house resolution for
revenues it's still combined
but when we do the revenues in house
bill one it splits It Out by education
trust fund and
um general fund
so moving down the sheet going down the
rows so you get your various revenues
in the headers so business taxes meals
and rooms Tobacco liquor Etc going
across
Row one is fiscal year 2022.
it gives you what the official plan was
for fiscal year 2022.
and then what was actually collected and
reported in the akfer
and then a difference to that number
you move down to row eight
you have the official plan again
but now you have the governor's estimate
which just came out yesterday the day
before
then you have a rows 11 and 12 it says
agencies low and high estimates
that's there due to what you saw today
with dra where they give you a range
once we have that range I will plug the
range into these cells so that the
committee has it in front of them
and then row 13 would be where you would
make your final estimates as to what you
think the revenue might be
you can see that under column D which is
liquor transfer there's already a number
in there of 130 million for for liquor
because when they came to you
they presented that as what they
believed their fiscal 23 would be
that same exercise is done for 24 and
fiscal 25.
all these numbers
will be based on current law
so fortunately
the governor didn't propose rate changes
he didn't propose
um you know other changes to the
business tax such as there was last
biennium
so you don't see a lot of we won't have
a lot of changes from what the governor
said to what is in this document the
only place you're going to see a change
is in the CST
the communication Services tax where the
governor has said or has proposed that
he believes that should be repealed in
this document
it's not there today but when you get it
next time you'll see a number that would
have been the base number the reason
it's not there today is that I didn't
have it yet from the governor's office
so if you look at column G
hou for fiscal year 24 you're going to
see there's nothing there and the same
for 25. uh yeah fiscal year 25.
I'll populate that with a number which
would be the base number
and then if the house agrees that you
think removing or repealing the
communication Services tax is a good
idea
we would reflect that on the Surplus
statement
so we would make a negative adjustment
of an amount on the Surplus statement
represent fellows
so in order to have an Apples to Apples
comparison
we take the governor's Revenue estimates
and we put the base revenues back in so
whatever the governor's base revenues
were before he made final decisions on
um
changes that he might want to make to
revenue such as repealing the
communication Services tax so on this
document
in column G
row 16 there's going to be a number
there it's not there today because I
didn't have it when I put this together
I got it now I just don't didn't have it
when I put this document together
that number
will be used as you do your estimates
based on current law
but at the end of the day if the house
as a body says we don't want the
communication Services tax we want to
repeal that
the LBA would carry a negative
adjustment on the Surplus statement so
we would make sure that your
unrestricted revenues reflected that
so that when the budget's being prepared
it would still remain in balance
anybody else with a question
yep
see akfer is the annual comprehensive
financial report
uh I didn't change it the
yeah the the
um
[Music]
the board that oversees the the
annual report that requires it as part
of their standards
apparently kafir has some uh negative
meaning to it potentially
I'm not I I don't have enough to say
other than that
I I
that that some some buddy was insulted
by the use of kafir so they can change
it to akver
okay all right we've got an hour so
let's use it why is it
perhaps we could start working from the
back forwards because it's small or
steady well that was something that
Chris mentioned that maybe we could take
a look at fish and game and
see if we can do something there which
is on the back end of the presentation
what do you think so yeah that's fine if
you want to turn to page nine
yes uh just do a confirm or whatever I
think what was said is he was going to
start this afternoon on the ones where
there's almost no variability so that
way it's not going to take much time for
us to do those doesn't really matter
where they are in the packet it's just
the ones we can easily do yes
well so if you look at we can start with
fishing game because it's I think fairly
straightforward
if you look at the um
basically there's two categories of
Revenue and the unrestricted fishing
game they have fishing game licenses and
then all other
the fish and game licenses has been
estimated to be about 9.8 million
dollars the agency recommended that the
governor has agreed with that
the official plan for 23 was 9.8 million
so they don't expect a lot of
fluctuations and if you recall the
director
um I think there was a question about
during covet how there was a spike with
licenses and now it's coming back to
more of the norm of what they expected
but when people were home they saw an
influx of a fishing license people
buying their fishing licenses that maybe
hadn't done it for many years and
getting out in the woods so that they're
away from people
um but that seems to be bouncing back
out or they're anticipating bouncing
back out into 23 and forward
the governor and the official plan for
fiscal year 23 for the other Revenue had
3.5 million
part of the difference there is if you
recall fish and game came in and they
said we actually know how much we're
getting in the um
those two Revenue sources they got just
over a million dollars each related to
transfers from other agencies for the
ohrv and um unrefunded road toll ohrv
and snowmobiles so they had gotten that
amount so that's what makes up the
difference between the three five and
the three nine that you see for fiscal
year 23.
24 and 25 you can see that the governor
and the agency are basically giving you
the same
same suggestion
representative Southworth
um maybe you said this when I was a so
are we doing a similar process where you
would just make a motion to accept
the ones for fish and game then it would
be seconded any discussion and then we
would vote is it going to be like that
that would be my thought uh but I want
to just hear if you know if there's a
thousand questions and we realize oh
well we have we really can't decide but
we would start with a motion so we get
it on the table so yeah yeah I'd be glad
to make a motion okay to accept the
estimates uh from Fish and Game second
yeah
um for 24 and 25. the agency runs for 24
and 25 thank you
for 23 24 and 25
that's good school year that's three
years yeah yeah definitely I guess we
would have to do all three yes I agree
and we could do them one at a time I'm
just trying to see what we want exactly
this is a great place to start second
motion is okay second in by
representative Platt
uh any discussion about that
yes representative so I had one one
question I have is we you know we have
all these handouts did we get one from
fishing games
so see it
yeah it was quite a while ago oh
it was a single page long sheet oh
and it was the unrefunded road toll
for ohrv and Marine that came in at a
million when it was budgeted for 800 000
and a million won when it was budget for
the 900 so that's for 23 that's the the
difference that you see about the 400
000 difference you see between what the
governor had what the plan had and what
the agency came in with for 23.
foreign
excuse me representative jewelry
yeah and representative fellows that
number will re remain the same or
increase as more people from
Massachusetts come up here and don't pay
or don't ask for a refund on the road
toll when they get gasoline for their
ATVs and their snowmobiles
because they no one tells them they
can't and I'm not about to
in the grand scheme of things it is like
one million dollars
on a 14 billion dollar budget but
okay so uh the Strava we have on the
table is to accept the agency estimates
for fish and game fund for 2023 2024 and
2025.
all those a favor just
representative
yep go ahead representative
usually we we
um
abbreviate these numbers
we we round the numbers
on rather than do what what
they've done here every dollar does
count for them but
but on sometimes we've had discussions
of okay are we going to on in 23 are we
going to 13.8 or are we going to
to 14.
but we do round the numbers yep that's
correct
so if you you can see how the nine eight
that's that's kind of the typical way
that you would come through with this
committee so you would look at the 3964
and you might say let's leave before or
leave it at three nine you make a
decision on what you're comfortable with
and this agency's uh example I would say
you're probably more comfortable going
to four because they've said they've
gotten in those two large revenues that
bump it up by 400 000. slightly over
four hundred thousand dollars
um more than what they'd anticipated
and then on for 24 and 25 you got three
five seven you could round up to three
six and then from there we would total
that out to be the Thirteen four
good yeah go ahead are we do we have to
estimate column A and B or just do we do
only C
I would ask you to do anything that
isn't already if you're comfortable with
nine eight you leave nine eight but if
it's three five seven the committee
should direct me as to whether you want
it to go up to three six or stay at
three five
so so you
there's there are times when the
committee's um it's this isn't a great
example but we'll say like the business
taxes where you maybe you come in with a
a high and a low and you do an average
and it's 0.5 and then you say okay we're
going to go to the higher number or the
lower number but it's an agreement that
the committee makes because that's what
you're comfortable with so let me just
check back with representative
Southworth who made the motion for the
straw vote uh were you saying that you
want us to accept the total like column
C
for each of the fiscal years or did you
want to
amend that
thank you what I believe is I wanted to
get the discussion going so I want to
get the discussion part but I think
amending it as several have suggested to
3.6 I think we can go through each of
those numbers and pretty easily agree on
what to do so okay sounds good I was
flexible all right so all of those in
favor of accepting these as rounded
um just raise your hand or say aye one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten okay everyone anyone opposed
okay so it looks good to just race down
those numbers and round at them
so that for so that Chris knows whether
we're talking about 0.5 or 0.6 yes I can
say what I think you wanted if that
would be easier yes so fiscal year 23
you would have 9.8 under the fish and
game licenses
4.0 for all other and the total would be
13.8
okay under fiscal year 24 row 16 you
would have 9.8
3.6
under the next column and then your
total would be 13.4
and that would be the same for fiscal
year 25.
okay great
so we had unanimous I don't know how
many people we have here one two three
three seven eight nine ten eleven
so sixteen to oh on our Scrabble okay
great
okay now uh back to representative
southward's point it's not we're not
just going in order here we're going in
terms of maybe Simplicity of numbers so
what would you point us to next if you
want to take a look at the highway fund
we can see if you're comfortable with
that if you're
I'll point to places but you need to
tell me if you're not ready to go there
yes page seven yep
I'm working on that
representative Army thank you I'm not
comfortable with this I'd like to see
what the the numbers of Highway users
has gone up to I've been I followed the
turnpike numbers but that leaves out
everybody coming from Canada and
a lot of the ones in Vermont coming
through and such
so um I think during the pandemic they
did actually produce numbers that that
the dot
or D.O.T I think dot collects the
turnpike information well not just the
turnpike information but the the miles
traveled on our roads
they they gave that to us during the
pandemic yeah and I'm I just don't
remember if it was safe I think it's a
D.O.T puts it together safety may have
gotten that from dot but I'd have to
double check with them I believe it it
was somehow they were doing traffic
checks
outside the turnpike system
and this is an example of we really
haven't gotten the governor's
thinking behind this and why his numbers
are changing over the years uh
representative who else has the hand
representative
yes and representative Army I think I
forgot my question for a moment so
you're not alone we were talking about
getting old
foreign
is this an area where we want to wait
until the the governor's budget person
comes and explains a little bit more or
what do you think guys
oh do you know anything that you want to
share well I would just point out that
um the total
um for 24 and 25 the governor and the
agency are the same it's 23 that there's
a slight variation
and it's related to the motor vehicle
fees
um but
here
yeah
and I think Steve might have talked some
about that when he came in
for his presentation back in January
yeah represent a question I forgotten
remembered is uh when do the uh electric
vehicle Deluge when's that going to hit
so you have a choice between electric
vehicle and an electric vehicle
that's good
uh yeah well just they're pushing it
like crazy for a couple of years yeah
yeah
well well so Chris is this am I hearing
that the committee would like to hold on
this
wait for the Governor's budget director
and would you like safety to come back
in to answer any questions
well I'm looking at it you're right it's
not that different from the agency's
estimate um it looked more up different
for the first year
but thoughts around the room
representative Ami yeah it it does look
about the same between them but they're
both assuming that the amount of money
coming into the highway fund is going to
be growing oh very slowly but growing
rather than Contracting we do have more
hybrids
on the road all the time
as well as the the much smaller number
of electric cars and the hybrids are
getting much better mileage than when it
was down at
minus 20 I was getting 35 miles to the
gallon going over the hills well
representative ulry did you have
something
going over the hills going up the hill
she was only getting 10. no
no
already over the hill
but
what
my point was
that they're going to be increasing its
slower numbers
not the hybrids uh no perhaps not the
hybrids but we do have a one cent gas
tax increase coming up
remember the four years the planet just
for the
under Jasper we increase the gas tax
on yes but didn't we we increased it
four cents all at once no didn't we I
don't think so the the last increase to
the gas tax was I believe was 4.2 cents
but that was restricted
so it's money that's not what you're
estimating okay
representative I think had
I think I answered it I think Chris I'm
on page 151 of the act for I think
that's where we have our 10-year
historical
of the gas tax I believe that's what I'm
looking at
so it looks like going back I mean take
aside from the pandemic
124 125 is pretty consistent with
regular road traffic not not assuming
any type of electric vehicle or
anything else okay thank you
representative orrs and then
representative Southworth
thank you madam chair uh Chris maybe you
could uh verify this and having done
this kind of work I mean I'm looking at
it's like this isn't even a rounding
error the differences in 2022 and the
fact that they're all so close
uh could you imagine us exceeding these
like this number where it's even in our
favor in 2022 if there was even a
rounding error in this
uh no we didn't so I think what again
you've heard some of the discussion when
dra was here
at the time these estimates were being
made we were just coming out of um covet
hibernation people were coming back to
the offices but they weren't sure how
quickly people were going to be back in
the offices people started traveling a
little bit more so I think when
um safety made its estimates they were a
little bit conservative because of some
of those concerns
and fortunately we exceeded what they
had planned for
yes yeah my focus is on the agency
estimates which look pretty consistent
for 23 24 and 25. so my sense is if we
don't approve it today
are there real questions that would
change our minds if we waited and I
don't want to lose questions but that's
what I'm always thinking we can always
keep Gathering more information but are
there really any things here that we
would change our mind about so maybe
it's
do you always want to make a motion
before there's a straw poll or let's see
I'm just thinking of a system but yeah I
know I know I'm not sure what works best
actually yet
we can certainly do the motion thing
just like we did last time okay you want
to do that yeah I'll make a motion to
accept the agency figures for 23 24 and
25 for the highway fund
I'll second that
okay honey do you want to just take a
vote real quick on that and then we can
go from there or do you want to discuss
it some more
up representative fellows we'll get into
a rhythm I just want to feel it I like
to slow down a little bit here so if
we're going to talk about
um the highway fund I'd really like an
opportunity for everybody to look in the
annual financial report and to get the
you know handouts that that agency gave
us so we can so I can like see my notes
and just see
what they told us about factors that
would influence
you know some adjustment to projections
because I just think we're moving really
too fast here that's you're moving too
fast for me I can tell you that right
okay representative only yeah I'd just
like to concur with that
I think that on this is a little bit
difficult
to predict and they did give us some
more information
that we should look at and there are
more consequences I think than fish and
game if we say that they're getting in
more than they do get in
because the budget is frequently having
to backfill the department at this point
representative someone have a hand up
over here yes representative Bolton
thank you chair chairwoman um I just got
the question like where does the
governor get his estimates if not from
like dra and uh Chris
the governor works with the agencies to
get his estimates and so they will meet
with the governor's budget director
they'll go through a process of you know
maybe there's some guidance that the
governor's office has that says you know
Revenue seems to be doing X and Y so
when you give me estimates incorporate
that
um I don't know for Highway funds if
there was anything specific or if they
just said safety you're the expert
because you collect the road toll what
are you seeing for trends
thank you you know I I can't that's
where uh director Gary would be able to
ask answer some of those questions in
terms of what their office did with the
agency
representative Platt and then
representative Spielberg Madam chair I
want to understand this process there
was a motion made and we could vote it
up or down uh but if it's a straw poll
so that's not binding us to anything
until we take a final vote right we
could come back and change them we could
definitely come back this is just get a
sense of where the committee is and I
haven't really I don't think we
fine-tune the process quite yet we'll
get to a rhythm but I just kind of want
to see where the committee wants to go
on this
um at some point we know we do have a
motion for a straw vote on the table so
we'll just at least see where we're at
if we're 50 50 obviously we're not going
to go forward yet
um and we'll see what we need to do next
if we're you know 19-1 then we'll go
from there I guess as we're just kind of
getting a sense of the committee today I
had recognized representative
spillsbridge will do that and then we'll
go around the room
thank you madam chair I'm prepared to
support the motion but I'm curious the
discrepancies are very minor
in 24 and 25 it's 200 up 200 down comes
out in the wash in the total up
are the discrepancies based on different
points in time for the Viewpoint is
there a different date at which the
governor's estimate was made in
conjunction with his agencies versus the
agency presentation we have
I don't think so I think it may be um if
you look at the sheet that department of
safety provided you
when you look at the road toll
there's
um three lines that fall under that I
suspect that they included two lines and
not all three I checked with Department
of Safety last night because I was
curious as to why there was a difference
and if they had done something different
with the governor and Steve suggested no
and he suggested that
The Gray Line that gets you to 125
actually 124 3 125 and 126 for your road
toll is the number they would support
125.6
I haven't had a chance to talk to the
governor's budget director as you might
guess he was being pulled in many
directions yesterday
so we've we've emailed some but I
haven't had a conversation yet
representative Phyllis
so my other question is
I'm wondering why we don't have somebody
you know if we knew ahead of time which
agencies we were going to discuss why we
don't have somebody from that agency
just sitting here so you know when we
have questions we could just ask
somebody that knows it today we're just
kind of getting a feel for where the
committee is there may be some like we
found with fish and game that we are
pretty comfortable with what we had for
information we've already had the
presentation but in a case like this if
we if the straw poll ends up showing us
that we're we're not ready yet we know
when our next uh Revenue estimate
meetings are and we can certainly ask
those okay people to come back if we
need that's what we can decide yeah
basically we should be doing that right
now because we've got like
less than an hour to go so we just
should be saying we're really solid on
this one and we can say something or
else we need to skip this one and have
right we're using this as a test we're
just getting started and you know some
of you are new to this committee I don't
know your decision making Styles I don't
know how much information you need or
want I'm just trying to get a feel for
it I'm at your service so we'll we'll do
whatever the committee feels we need
well that's where but we do have a
motion on the table so let's just get a
sense what is the vote we have a straw
vote uh to accept the agency total
estimates for 23 24 and 25. all those in
favor please raise your hand one two
three four five six seven eight nine
ten eleven twelve so we have twelve for
that and how many opposed raise your
hand one two three four so it's a twelve
to four
um I want you guys to be comfortable
so let's let's hold off on this you know
at least we made a note of that and if
we can we can go back let's go back to
it on the 27th I believe it's the next
time we get together
and uh how about this why don't you look
through your notes
and see if you can understand it
yourselves look at or go online and look
at the presentations online
um and if you still feel like you have
burning questions either send those
questions to us
or we'll invite the agency head to come
out does that sound reasonable
okay representative question for Chris
Chris what page on our official
financial report would we find the
fiscal year 2022 Highway fund or Road
gas toll it says 123.918
all right is on page 151 151 yeah and
what column so you're going to go down
to the experiment Dave
gas tax
all right but I'm looking at this number
here oh yeah that's different it is
different I I just want just any idea
how different it is why is it different
well maybe you can look at that okay
it's the 123.9 is different than the
122.1 I see on the official
report here
okay well
we can continue on I just want to see if
Chris can somehow okay drive together
yeah good question okay so we'll we will
this will be on the list I'm going to
make a list here things we can check off
things that uh we want to maybe revisit
but you guys are gonna have to do your
own personal homework go back read your
stuff see if you can answer your own
questions or see what really remains and
we will get those questions answered
okay
so
yes I've posted notes everywhere
so Chris is there another agency you
would care to identify for us
uh page five
you have the swept the column p
I mean it's statutorily driven to be 263
1 and 23 and then it goes back up to 363
1 and 24 and 25.
so it's it's an easy one I think again
it's
representative Platinum I move 2631 for
fiscal year
2023 and 360.
huh
foreign
can you clarify your motion are you
simply moving
um swept right now column p
yeah that's all I'm doing okay yep and
so I moved 263 one like I said in in uh
pistol 23 and 363 one for 24 and 25.
which is by law
is there a second second
okay
uh more discussion on that
okay uh all those in favor of accepting
the agency estimates for swept for 23 24
and 25 raise your hand
two three
okay everyone great thank you okay so
that one we can check off on that list
representative Olney
can I make a motion for Medicaid
recoveries yes please and I explained it
on that we accept the
uh that's the same page it's right next
to column Q
yeah
M8 recoveries that's Medicaid recoveries
um
oh except I just no they're they're
doing high and low is the same so uh
that we accept the agency numbers of 2.6
million and 23 2 million and 24 and 2.1
million and 25.
and I'm doing that
because they may be off by a hundred
thousand or so
but they they are not getting very much
money out of this it's a tiny amount of
money relative to their overall budget
and vintesimal amount of money
and
um
and I think we should just go with that
we're not going to get any more
information
okay we have a motion to accept Medicaid
recoveries uh agency estimates right so
do we have a second on that yes Beverly
uh representative Ames and the
representation
um I say that the governor's estimate oh
for these is 2.5
so it seems to me that we ought to know
uh representative
my question's the same I'm wondering why
the governor's estimate is so low at 1.8
um I don't know if that's a typo or
um
and then it yeah it evens out when you
look at three years combined
yeah
yeah okay I guess maybe we need to ask
the governor's person
all right so we have a motion
any more discussion on that oh and I am
in the motion
sure that we wait until the 27th when we
can listen to the governor's first so
we're basically not doing that all right
well hold off so that'll be on the
January 27th list kind of order yes
um for a simple one like that doesn't
make more sense to Simply email him we
might have the answer tomorrow it may be
a very simple thing I love it I mean
it's still I'd like to have the person
here on the 27th but some of these
questions might be able to be answered
really quickly
like you said the other was like an
anomaly that it wasn't the same so right
and I'll happily reach out and try to
get answers so yeah we'll have a lot of
questions today and then if you send us
say these are the five questions and we
are it's easy to answer these three but
they'll come for these two yes if it's
something simple like that doesn't that
doesn't require like discussion then
let's just get a quick answer to the
question we'll do another straw poll on
the 27th see where we're at from there
okay I saw a hand up over here saying
these numbers are so small yeah to try
to finagle them so what what are we
accomplishing so accept them in my view
well we haven't we had a motion that was
amended to hold off basically so you
pulled your motion
yeah
was there is someone else would like to
make a motion
uh does someone want to propose
something I'll make the motion to
restore the motion
okay
so we're gonna go with
2023 what do we say 2.6 million
2024 2 million
2025 2.1 million
is there a second
okay all right
all right all right let's just do a vote
on that all those in favor of supporting
those numbers raise your hand one two
three four five
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen everyone so okay uh that one
worked and I'll still reach out to the
director to see why there's a slight
variation
yeah
you can always have a motion to read Etc
well absolutely again this is trying to
get a feel for Where We Are
today again if you go back over the
weekend and you want to do the Deep dive
on these presentations again go for it
is maybe you see something that you want
to talk about again okay so how about on
page four
tobacco settlement
column n
you'll see that the governor accepted
the agency's estimates that were
presented before this committee
January 25th I think it was or maybe
February 7th one of those two dates
but representative Ames
hi Chris
it seems to me that there is a periodic
events with the settlement money that
sometimes make a difference I mean
they're on an unexpected
happenings and I know that's happened in
the past and is there a
is there a time when they do an update
on this or maybe we should check on that
I don't know because we can it can
sometimes be multiple millions and it
has been in the past
so the short answer is no they find out
in April when the settlement's
distributed
um
they'll it usually come not usually it
has come in in two payments
um and then they'll get a final number
for the current year you're in so in
April you'll know 23
there may be something
um that doj is aware of that could
influence slightly what they've
suggested for 24 and 25 but I believe
when the attorney was here
um he talked about that there's there's
a lot of unpredictables that get mixed
into this that they just can't consider
at this time
um so when they do their estimates they
tend to be fairly conservative so that
they don't give you too much idea of an
influx of money
um but I would say that you know in
April when you see what they get
if they don't come back to um Senate
ways and means that this committee may
have them come in and just say where you
at today and has that changed anything
you gave us so another way of answering
that is that there may be that kind of
new information but it's going to be too
late for us that would be good to go
with these numbers right
yes representative Southworth
so from my perspective really these
numbers are just for budgeting purposes
and that's something that could happen
it's kind of what they said no I I was
asked um no I mean these numbers here
are for budgeting purposes but in terms
of what the settlement actually does
they said it real basically was
unpredictable that's correct and in
response to that uh one of the represent
fellows maybe asked for the
10-year period of getting the you know
what was predicted or planned for and
what was the actual payment or maybe
those reps involve me I sent that to the
committee members and you'll see that it
fluctuates
um
by a few million almost every year
so you get you may get a few million
more or less than what's been budgeted
and again it depends on factors that the
attorney suggests that he has no
influence over
representative
yes and as I remember the one huge
variation that we had was at the time
when they finally were settling cases
that they'd been arguing over for four
or five years and almost all of them got
settled the same year in fiscal 2013 and
he doesn't believe there's much like
that out there now right in fiscal 2013
um
the plan had called for 42.4 million
you actually got 63.2 million in and
it's as a result of what rev savomi's
talking about there was a number of
issues in the master settlement
agreement that hadn't been fully
resolved many of those were finally
resolved and as a as a result of that
the states were trued up in what was
owed to them
since then
you've seen fluctuations uh
as high as 10.9 million above the plan
or 2.6 million below the plan
since 2017 everything has been slightly
above the plan or significantly above
the plan
representative
I don't think based on the testimony we
heard and the numbers that we saw I mean
I really
I don't think we have a whole lot of
basis within this committee to tweak
these numbers all that much I mean even
even the testimony we heard was
he throws darts every year and uh for
lack of a better description so I mean I
would be willing to accept these numbers
based on the fact that there's really
not much we could do with that and even
the agency was unsure where we go from
one year to the next
representative spilsbury
I'm pretty much echoing what's been said
but what I recall the testimony is he
said the only thing he's sure of is that
the number is wrong
and so from a budgeting perspective we
shouldn't be budgeting for an unforeseen
bonus
what he was really forecasting is a
continued declining trend
did I see a hand over here
okay do we want a motion
okay is there a second
chamber okay excellent okay so the
motion on the table or as a straw vote
is that we accept the agency estimate
for
23 24 and 25 all those a favor raise
your arm please thank you looks like
it's unanimous yeah
okay so uh we will continue on and we
won't need to revisit that unless you
come up with a reason why we need to
great choice
the the next one I'm going to point you
to I'm not suggesting that you need to
act on it today but I just need to know
if there's any questions is the lottery
and column m
so I just if they're I think there was
some questions the other day and if
there's certain questions that I need to
ask the Lottery Commission to let me
know what those are
I definitely got the sense that we
needed to hear more from them
but I'm not sure I have a list of
questions yet but please speak up folks
yes representative Ames all me sorry
uh yes on the one that I was most
interested in was a breakdown which that
he'd always given us before a breakdown
by game type of game on and the trend
the trend in scratch tickets the trend
in in Super Bowl
Powerball not Super Bowl
and the rest of them on
Powerball and Mega Millions are are
pretty much
like putting your money in a slot
machine you might win or you might not
but but
on but the scratch tickets are are
fairly consistent
one way or another and
um
yeah
and the the charitable gaming money we
spending a lot of time on as money is
not much representative Southworth I
guess just double checking
um was there somewhat of an anomaly for
2023 whether it was a big pot or
something like that the Senate seems
steady it was there's been several
um Powerball Mega Millions 2023 was
higher it wasn't enough that's some of
it yes yes thank you but I to represent
almi's point I think the committee does
deserve the breakdown by the various
Revenue sources so I will reach out to
the Lottery Commission to ask for that
and then ask them to come in either on
the 27th or 28th and then the sports
betting is
I think one of the just taking off
which is unfortunate but anyway
representative Phyllis yeah I I remember
that um the commissioner didn't bring
something with him to the presentation
that we had because he'd been on
vacation so I don't know if we got that
presentation but I I think I'd like to
go through the whole thing again just
that his you know not asking him about
what the lottery does anymore but just
focusing on why are these why are these
your estimates because some things are
volatile and there are some things that
I believe he probably is taking into
account the activity in other states so
we may lose some some of those programs
like the you know he's talking he was
talking about like betting on your
telephone you know that
so I don't do any of that so I don't
know very well but that that
Massachusetts picking that up means we
probably will go down so I that that's
the part I would like to hear all over
again yeah so it sounds like we should
request uh someone from the lottery to
come back and explain that in more depth
yep that'd be great anyone else yes
representative orrs
thank you madam chair and thank you
Brett fellows for bringing that up I
mean that was a disaster I couldn't
believe it so yes I think we need every
yes
representative all me and then flood
yeah um but that remind we did ask for a
fiscal note on a bill I think last time
that hasn't come yet it has oh good and
I didn't see it represent a put
yes uh they got a plethora
of games out there scratch cards and all
that stuff is there a saturation point
where they add one more it doesn't grow
the pot
yeah I think
a good question for
um the director
I mean what we've heard him talk about
in this committee before scratch tickets
seem to be
steady you know that seems to be a very
reliable Revenue Source it's your Mega
Millions and powerballs and and those
types of games that sometimes fluctuate
because people
um tend to play those when there's
bigger jackpots and may not play them as
often when there's not and then you have
the sports betting issue that is
taking off a little bit more quickly
than I think they anticipated and maybe
it's leveling out I don't know but I
think these are all appropriate
questions for Charlie and his his team
to
discuss with this group
representative ulrey yeah could you talk
to the commissioner as well and ask him
the question is uh fiscal year 2023 he's
got an anomaly coming in but we've had
two Within
eight weeks 10 weeks of each other of a
half billion well one was a billion
dollars and the other was a half billion
the take to New Hampshire was relatively
large in both of those and I is that
2023 year or is it 2024 year on those
and I'm not sure where it splits it
should be 23. I believe it's all 23 that
you're referencing but again
we would need to just confirm with
Charlie yeah that's that's how much is
and
for some members of the committee just
to regard
ah
the list of the different programs that
are out there and which one and two
dollar tickets pay out the best would be
and where the prize tickets still reside
where's the fellows
um yes I'm also you may know the answer
to this I thought
for sure the scratch tickets and the the
you know the the Powerball all those
kinds of games definitely went to the
trust fund education trust fund I
thought the sports betting was different
but is that not correct is everything
that everything any anything
um
the
Lottery Commission
overseas all of that goes to the
education that's correct okay thank you
yeah so they they have the lottery fund
which is what they do their day-to-day
business out of and at the end of
I think it's that every month they do a
transfer not think I know and every
month at the end of every month they do
a transfer and that transfers the
revenue or profit that they don't need
for their day-to-day business that goes
to the education trust fund
charitable gaming
yes
it's it's in the Constitution I mean all
the lottery uh Revenue defined as net of
costs and maybe and set aside for
uh problem gaming fund and that kind of
thing all the revenue has to go pour
into the education in into the education
trust fund
all right we'll definitely have a
lottery come back with more information
uh a lot more information and I just
wanted to clarify too that the lottery
did come in with a presentation they
didn't have Revenue information in it it
was just an overview of their department
but they did give us an email based on a
question of what their projections were
that I forwarded to the committee and
that's how we have the numbers in there
for the 170.8 158 and 163. and we just
need to have that fleshed out so we can
ask questions no understood I just
wanted to to give Charlie a little bit
of credit for something yeah you know he
did do that and we appreciate that it's
just we obviously have a lot more
questions I'm sorry uh representative
and then representative yeah ask them
what the odds are of them being right me
yes on somebody mentioned saturation
saturation is a cultural number on in
Massachusetts when Charlie joined us
about 10 years ago on the amount per
capita including the babies that was
being gambled in the counties on
Massachusetts counties next to New
Hampshire
was one thousand one hundred dollars and
something
mm-hmm
so uh and New Hampshire was Way Beyond
behind that I didn't see a number but
but on and in looking at the big casinos
in Casino studies that were done by a
pro Casino paid Casino person on the New
Hampshire was the lowest spending in in
the region
now we are being set they are increasing
our saturation levels right now so so we
could have considerable growth in this
not that I would like it but we could
have considerable growth in this still
to come
okay
yes representative
that would also bring up the question
regarding our sports betting and how
much that will decline
uh with Massachusetts developing their
sports betting uh again
as an estimate but Charlie's pretty good
at
estimating he did warn us off the 50
tickets that cost Massachusetts a whole
bunch of money
yeah
but that's
you know that's going to be an assault
on revenue from that particular aspect
although so far it doesn't look like the
sports betting has done anything in Mass
7 500 dollars
I have no idea
all right so we we obviously need a
presentation from them we didn't get the
full-fledged one so we'll we'll
definitely schedule that for the 27th uh
there may be a few other small
categories we could take a look at in
our short amount of time on this page I
see maybe uh column I
what do you guys think
they're estimates then this year
the governor's estimate there's a tiny
one I guess but actually
I take that backs the in O3 the agency
thinks it's getting in more than the
governor but in general the courts have
usually gotten in less than we tell them
that we're going to get in
when we try to increase them
a question for representative Southworth
yes I do notice and I wonder again if
it's anomaly type stuff that often the
governor is a little different in 23 but
then he's exactly the same in 24 and 25.
so I'm wondering if that's really a big
issue exactly what happened in 23 if by
24 and 25 he's matched everything up
again I would need to confirm with the
governor's budget director but I suspect
it's maybe some of its rounding when
they were putting together their numbers
they didn't go out to the the 10th you
know
all right representative ulery then aims
and then
we need to remember that on court fees
uh that a good portion of that is split
with motor vehicle because mailing goes
to department for some unknown reason
mailings go to the Department of Safety
and don't get counted in the General
Revenue but get
put in the General Revenue wow if you go
to court it goes in through and is
recorded as Court piece
um I don't know how to correct that and
I and I know that safety doesn't want to
correct it because I have a
I have a fish and they've got a skimming
net in there somewhere but oh yeah
yeah I I would be in order to move some
numbers
okay
um well then I I would move for
the court finding fees column I
um
13.8
or fiscal year 23
13.9 for 24.
14.1 for 25.
is second uh representative all me I
guess is right there okay uh any more
discussion on this that I've missed
all right uh all those in favor of
accepting that motion raise your hand
excellent unanimous
we do not need to revisit that
check I'm wondering about something
um that's large can you turn on your
microphone because we can't hear you
yeah sorry uh other
we can't predict other at all
uh
it's up to das if we want to hold on to
it to the end and ask them have you
changed anything
then that's one thing but other than
that
uh just one thing before you go with
other yeah you'll notice that the
governor's got a number of 97 I put a
number of 111.
and so I reached out to the governor's
director on that one in particular
he believes his number and there was
already some of the interest that the um
the treasurer discussed with you was
already kind of baked into the other
number that he had I have it as a
separate number so I need to confirm
what's correct for at least 23 24 and 25
you could go forward with that but I
would ask the committee just to hold 23.
just till I get an answer I don't want
you to put 111 and then find it was
wrong the other thing I'd like to point
out with the other is at the bottom
you'll see the amount of the interest
Revenue that's being included
in those numbers and you see that
they tie right to the governors in 24
and 25 so
I just I just need to clarify 23 for you
good
representative Ellery yeah since it's
apparently decided what to do with other
yeah
so that's a thought I would like to move
the moves the estimates of 13.2 13.2
13.2 that sounds repetitive because it
is
okay do we have a second
invite representative janigan
any questions comments representative
Rochford okay you've been all those in
favor accepting that motion raise your
hand one two
yeah
it's illegal can't do that all right
that's unanimous
although I can give you a discount
no then I go out of business but okay
Securities uh
representative would you like to just
discuss that a little bit I just don't
want to make all the Motions but is
there someone who'd like to make a
motion to approve securities right right
next to you
four and 46.6 million
is there a second representative okay
okay uh any discussion questions
comments
all those in favor raise your arm white
people want to get out of here don't
they okay looks like it's unanimous
thank you
well it is an accomplishment to think of
the number we've got
yeah it's fun to check I'm gonna check
mark
uh Chris are there other things that you
might want us looking at that could be
simple I think maybe the only other one
might be Liquor on page three column d
unless there's some need for additional
information there
representative Ulrich
as liquor indicated that the decline
that took place during covet has changed
or are they still running
kind of lower than the anticipated
they're not running
um lower the issue you've seen the last
three years is there's been an extra
amount deducted from their revenue
before it got to the general fund
so the granted Advantage the the
Medicaid expansion fund
so during covid and the in two years
after with the increased roles the
Medicaid expenses have been more than
originally budgeted
it was put in statute that the
commissioner could request a transfer
from The Liquor Commission to fill that
Gap
so in 21 20 20 and 21 it was about eight
million dollars and then
22 it was about 7 million they don't
expect to do that again in 23 or going
forward but it's so that's what
so their revenue has come down but a
little bit because of that but they were
trending
upwards
right their forecast was up but there's
that and there's another 10 to 11
million that gets transferred so when
you look at their presentation you'll
see their their gross line is going up
but then they subtract some and then the
amount going to the general fund has
been a little less than anticipated
follow-up no no okay representative
Mommy
uh yeah isn't it
they don't expect to be doing that next
year because we're going to have to come
up with a plan to finance or get rid of
expanded medicaid
and it might not be that way no
um so that they expect the Medicaid
rolls will start to come down yeah and
at then the cost associated with that
will come down and they think they
should be they be in the department of
health and human Human Services should
be able to manage within that Revenue
stream that they have for uh the granted
advantage and not need the extra bump
from Liquor Commission okay so that's
unrelated to that other one
I do know there is a difference between
the governors and the agencies uh do you
know anything about that one
so we probably should
um could the governor be doing current
law which is that Medicaid expansion
hasn't been approved yet
for the next
yeah that's a good question
so does does Medicaid expansion have to
be reauthorized for this next budget
it does well I think it's fiscal it
needs to be done by fiscal 24. so I
think the idea was that it might be
worked on some this year
I I don't know where that's at I I know
there was some potential bills being
introduced but I don't know what the
the flavor of it is and I don't know
what's
going to happen with some of the funding
mechanisms that were in place
I wonder folks is this something that we
want to hear from the governor's budget
office or or are you comfortable making
a decision on I think we need to hear
from
I guess
I mean to me the question would be that
simple is
um did in fact they have not accounted
for the Medicaid expansion here and
that's what the difference is
and again if they do do current law
which is what these numbers are supposed
to be
um you would take that out
but he never has used current law and
never presentations and I bet he has a
couple of times but
so representative fellows yeah so I I
think they're also still building new
liquor stores so that can might have
some kind of impact on
their revenues so
they come back they can help us yeah to
me it's saturated they build more liquor
stores it increases convenience but
doesn't necessarily increase sales but
they they differ they they think they
get more sales at every store
all right sounds like we're not ready to
make a decision on this one we need
questions answered and maybe some time
to look back on their presentation
think about other concerns questions you
might have
unless someone
feel strongly about something I'm going
to go home and contribute to the liquor
tax
Madam chair representative orrs and then
representative Almy uh also uh I thought
we were about done on that but I thought
can we look at insurance tax today or
that one looks like a no-brainer unless
I'm missing something
all right uh I'm open to looking at
insurance tax if the rest of the group
is
uh
yeah
well or or at least look at your
paperwork and see if but we're gonna
have to ask a question we'll ask the
question about the does the governor's
numbers take into account Medicaid
expansion or not how does that work
don't know if we need a presentation yet
from liquor think about that as you get
we get another 10 days before we see we
have to schedule anything so represent
all me thank you sir the insurance
department has always but I guess
because the woman who always did it
finally did not come this year uh
uh they've they've taken us through the
heart and the soft markets for different
parts of the insurance tax
and I felt really odd getting just an
overall number period
I don't know if we could get out of them
what their actuaries think is happening
to the different markets for the
different parts of insurance
representative fellows um yeah for the
the insurance I mean in the in FY 22
they have 155 million and then the the
plan for 2003 there those numbers are
all a lot lower so I think we need an
explanation of why they actually gave
that to us well I don't remember
well and this is where maybe just we
need a little time and we have it enough
we have a solid week to go back to our
notes look back at the presentation see
if we understand it if we don't we
absolutely have them come back but
that's when I actually remember
it's up to you if we want them to come
back we can certainly do that or if you
want to just look at our notes and come
back and discuss it some more
or we can make a decision whatever
whatever you guys want to do today
I don't think we had a motion
yeah I was about to make a motion but
with the intervening conversation I
think maybe it's best hell till next
time we meet
yeah I really
for 20 years but but the the part
different parts of insurance the health
the Property and Casualty the the uh
life insurance and such on and where the
actuaries think that market is going is
is something that we did use to get and
I'm hoping that they were considering
but I don't know because it's a totally
new Department
so is the group thinking that we would
like someone to come back and
present that and explain it or just
email us the information you would like
them to come either one but could you
reach out to them and see something they
could do and if they can come even if
it's for 15 minutes that might be
helpful I yeah and I would suggest that
maybe you'd want them in the room
because I I think it's a more
complicated Revenue source
um the way that the prepayments work the
way that they have to reconcile the way
that the rates are different for
property versus Health
um I think it would I would suspect
there might be some questions that would
be best just to have them here okay
great then we will we'd love to have
them back
all right
far the short shortest presentation I've
never heard in front of them oh
representative motion to adjourn
just one before you do that just one
quick thing for you guys no more
projections no more estimating Just So
based on your actions today you'll get
this document back it'll be updated with
um penciled in essentially with the
agreement that you have on those certain
revenues you'll then see the agency low
and high for the dra for their revenue
sources and in addition there'll be in a
new sheet in the packet it's going to
look like this and I'll pass it around I
did it quickly during the lunch break so
I think it's all right but I need to
just want to double check it but just
want to show you what happens with the
information that dra gave you
thank you
foreign
so I'll I'll probably clean it up a
little bit more but basically you can
see what the business taxes
um the Dre gave you their low and high
for 23
and then they reduce that by the impacts
that of the tax law changes that haven't
been considered to give you a new
um kind of net revenue for the business
tax again a range the high low
that number is then carried up into 24.
so you'll see that
um
1219.5 is the low for 24.
and 1282.2 is the high at two percent
because I'm taking the 125 7.1
increasing that by 102 percent so that
creates that range and from that you're
going to take away the 25 million
dollars and come up with what would be
your net revenue
that's different than when you go down
to meals and rooms
you have the 423
455 5 as you're low and high
and then it stays at zero percent and
grows by five percent
you'll see that on row 11 there's that
transfer that number is subtracted after
you do your growth because that's a
transferred
of the the gross revenue to come up with
your new net revenue unlike the business
tax where that's a change it's going to
change the revenue going forward
and that happens for
um
the real estate transfer and the
interest in dividends is the same as the
business where you're decreasing the
amount of Revenue so you're accounting
for that compounding effect by taking
the lower base after you've netted out
the the tax law changes
so this sheet will be
included in the worksheet next time you
get the worksheet sent to you so that
you will at least have that information
you can kind of look at that I'll send
you the Excel so you can
um
tweak in that if you have ideas or
thoughts you want to come up with so
when we come back on the 27th and 28th
that's I think this is when it's going
to get a little bit more challenging
than you saw today because it's going to
be members are going to have their own
ideas and what they think should be the
best place to land and remember
these are ranges that the dra provided
it does not mean the committee has to
stay in that range if there's reasons
why the committee believes it should be
higher or lower than a range that's
perfectly acceptable there's nothing
binding about these ranges that is to
help the committee get a starting point
excellent thank you so much we got some
good work done today but um obviously we
have a lot more to do and we're going to
really try to get it done February 27th
and 28th and then on March 1st hopefully
be able to put it all together for
formal house resolution
yes representative Ames yeah
uh
and Chris surely you know but for the
resolution
is it the number before transfers that
goes into the resolution
or after uh and I'm talking about
transfers to you know in the meals and
rentals to to it'd be the after number
is the after the transfers right is our
job to figure that transfer number or no
no your job is to to come up with what
you believe is the
estimate that is the correct estimate so
just say I just
started packing up so I moved my sheet
anyways just say that um with the meals
and rooms you pick a midpoint between
the the range yeah
that we would adjust that at deduction
to that midpoint to come up with a new
what your net revenue would be
so you're going to so the in the
resolution that's what you would have is
the net revenue because it's going to be
removed anyways
it's not going to be something that can
be spent by the the finance committee on
the on the operating budget that's right
we do figure that the growth if you will
the gross number
um and then there's a mathematical
calculation that will bring it down to
the net number right I mean it's easy
with red because it's a five million
dollar deduction right it's a little bit
more complicated with the meals and
rooms because you got the transfer to
the municipal Revenue fund as well as
the school building Aid piece so those
both got to be considered
fortunately Lindsay had told me at the
start of today they have a little cheat
sheet that she'll send me to help me
with that in terms of the calculation
and and we really need to do that so
that
um in addition to getting the revenue
right
um I
in the agency's recommended budget to
the governor the treasurer had included
the municipal Revenue piece as other
Revenue so we'll need to make sure that
appropriation is correct as well
if it stays in the operating budget on
another one the business Enterprise tax
and the business profits tax you're
going to do a calculation we're going to
we're going to be estimating the gross
and you're going to divide it out
yes yeah so so you'll see one of the
last worksheets I do for you will be the
split between the education trust fund
and the general fund so you'll see the
BET BPT speeding split today I mentioned
that the governor has and and you all
were aware that the governor is
recommending repealing the CST another
thing the governor is recommending is
how to do the education trust fund
general fund split for the business
taxes
um
it's basically taking 35 percent of the
total collected and depositing that into
the education trust fund versus the
method that's used now which directs a
portion of the rate collected into the
education trust fund so for instance the
bet
is set at 0.55 percent
0.5 percent goes to the education trust
fund point zero five percent goes to the
general fund so it's a little bit more
complication involved with doing the
split the business profits at 7.5 six
percent of that goes to the general fund
of the rate collected and one and a half
percent of the rate but is attributed
goes to the education trust fund
changing it to a flat percent after
gross would make it easier for everybody
involved but that's
reflected in his splits I'll give you
current what it would be under current
law and then we would make if the
committee excuse me if the house were to
accept that recommendation there'd be a
negative
adjustment or an adjustment to move
money into the right buckets if it
needed to
represent only
and just so that the new people know on
when
the general fund
on as well no when the education trust
fund is in deficit which for quite a
long time it was on the general fund is
obligated to send money over to it
but when the
the education trust fund is in Surplus
they can the budgeters can lapse the
Surplus to the general fund to pay for
things so there isn't a real
split legal split between those two
it's and we always wanted to combine
them back again but on the Optics
weren't very good for that some people
did some of us did
yeah well
I I see people
squirming in their seats because we did
say 230. so we will end I will tell you
in addition to the 27th 28th and March
1st plan ahead to March 7th and March
8th
March 7th we will hopefully hear the
remaining bill or two that we have I
think both of those would be second
committee bills and we will try to do
work sessions on three bills that I
think we want to talk a lot about more
which is one was House Bill 450 Mr
Schamberg's bill which has to do with
net operating loss another has to do
with representative doucetz Bill he's
gone which is the charitable gaming bill
and the third would be House Bill 486
reciprocal toll collection
so we'll allocate some
committee work session time to talk
about those again and see what we might
want to do
and then on the eighth we'll try to exec
as many bills as we can because then
we're starting to get really close to
deadlines
but first and foremost we want to get
through these Revenue estimates so take
the time folks to read through your
presentations talk to you know you know
kind of educate yourself think about
where you are on things so that on the
27th you're prepared with your questions
and comments and hopefully we can come
to a great consensus yes
I
don't know
right yeah I just wanted to get done as
much as we could because just in case we
have some bills that oh we need to amend
it we need to think about it we need now
I just want to give us a little wiggle
room there I would expect that we would
have session more
21st 22nd 23rd of March because
everyone's up again against that hard
hard deadline of March 16th right so all
the communities are going to be getting
all of their work done by then so it'll
be in the next week's calendar which is
usually a solid two days
so I'm thinking if we can stay to this
schedule we'll be in really nice shape
we'll have our revenues done we'll have
our bill hearings done we'll exec as
much as we can
I think we'd be in really good shape
yes representative Mommy
February revenues
on after we'd sent the first Revenue
estimates to
to the finance committee and on if there
seemed to be anything significant sent
them on to the finance committee so they
had a little bit more or less wiggle
room
yeah representative always mentioning
that you know if we find out after we we
finally get the February revenues which
wouldn't be until mid-march uh we could
maybe
talk to finance and update our
resolution but you know again we have to
we have to give them something and every
month we're going to want more data and
we will get it but we have to we have to
give them something to start with so
March 1st is our day
thank you all have a great great long
weekend